Espera mais uns minutinhos, tá? E a gente começa. Deixa eu só puxar as últimas mudanças que eu fiz no último Minuto Aqui Pro Ripo.
Para vocês pegarem os últimos updates.
Beleza. Me digam aí no chat.
O que vocês conseguiram idealizar de ontem. Como foi.
é difícil dormir. Não sei se para todo mundo, mas.
é difícil depois de uma aula assim tensa é difícil dormir. E aí, como foi.
Entrei querendo aprender sobre Ice querer.
Fazer um filho. Fala aí, Rafa. Pode falar.
Então tirou uma dúvida aqui.
Eu estava pensando hoje. Ontem você mostrou, começou explicando a criação do ambiente, fazendo aquele mini teste passando e tal.
E depois entrou na questão da especificação.
Ali, naquela parte de documentação, regras e tudo mais, né?
Não teria. Não teria que ter começado por essa parte da especificação, regras e tudo mais. E depois ir gerando aquela.
Onde eu passo um ao um* ou um* não me lembro.
Então não teria que ser nessa ordem. Não, lá no catorze quinze. Está começando com a especificação, com regras, essas coisas assim.
A ideia é que, como a gente não está criando a regra, a gente já recebeu essas regras. Então essa é A Grande Diferença Se Fosse A Gente Começar De Um Ambiente Green.
Então seria exatamente isso que você falou. A gente começa a definir, estipular, ver intenção e assim por diante.
A gente começa no final, estipular a regra, porque, na verdade, a gente está recebendo um bocado de documento que Já Vem De Algo Que Já Existe.
E daí a gente começa a inferir esse processo.
Por causa disso, entendeu?
é porque mesmo assim, eu fiquei pensando, pô mesmo existindo.
A gente está pegando aquelas regras. Por exemplo, vou criar aquele ambiente inicial de teste.
Ou se eu pego a regra e falo assim. Faça o celular o menor teste possível. A regra é essa. O Arquivo é Esse E Tal Tem Que Atingir Né Sei Lá O Valor Tal.
Quando você criasse, ele já ia fazer esse processo. Não.
Tá bom.
Exatamente. Só que a gente está partindo. Que isso já existe no ambiente. Então é algo que a gente está herdando os testes. A gente está herdando o ambiente legado. A gente está herdando essas coisas, mas sim, você está certo.
E aí?
Se fosse para a gente começar de um ambiente que não tivesse isso, a primeira coisa que a gente deveria fazer.
é exatamente esse processo. Quero começar a criar.
Cara.
O processo para poder garantir que aquela informação está válida. Que é exatamente isso que você quer saber. Pô.
Essa informação que a gente validou, a gente teria que ter criado a validação primeiro. Para ter certeza que ele funciona.
Mas o nosso contexto, essa validação já existe no contexto, e a gente vai usar. Ela.
Para injetar dentro do nosso processo de.
Finally de respect*driven Development, por exemplo.
Tá? é como se aquilo já existisse. Então já fosse algo lá do.
Isso.
No processo deles é, a gente está partindo do catorze e quinze para frente.
Tá beleza.
é perfeito. Exatamente, exatamente. é isso aí.
Hello.
Lua.
Hmm hmm.
Ontem boa noite aí pessoal.
Vale.
Ontem ontem minha comeu, os token lá eu não, terminei fui ver aqui. Agora em algum momento gerou a pasta temp new brain, lá nw brain eu, perdi que momento foi esse.
New Brain para mim, no geral. O que que.
Na brain que. Ele manda compactar e levar para o notebook lm.
Ah, tá. Ele na verdade já está lá.
No.
Ele já. Ele já tá aí. O que você faz? Em vez de descompilar, ele.
Ele na verdade, já está. Todos os Mds Files lá.
Para você.
Então essa pasta gerou no, meu notebook no meu computador, pessoal em algum momento e foi, isso que eu perdi.
Ah, tá. Eu também. Porque não era.
Ah, I see a gente chama ele e ele gera.
Esses caras. Esse Bild aqui.
Basicamente, ele pega tudo, pega os arquivos inteiros e compila o Zip.
Para a gente enviar. Mas eu deixo ele enzipado também. Aqui dentro do notebook. Lm.
Não deve ter sido isso.
Sure.
Hamon. Pode perguntar. Deixa eu compartilhar na tela. Aqui.
Okay e cheguei na parte do brd.
Softly.
Por algum motivo ele não estava gerando com as onze exceções da ele, estava gerando somente com seis.
E passou um bom tempo hoje à tarde consegui gerar ele, com as nossas sessões ele, dá ok.
Okay.
Mas eu não consigo.
Progredir a, partir daí.
Então os erros de.
Uh.
De ambiente basicamente.
Você pediu para a Lime para ver qual era o problema no ambiente. Está usando Windows.
Mas. Eu consegui instalar o wcl tô rodando tudo no.
Tá? Mas ainda pode ser alguma coisa de herança, tá? A gente vê hoje, tá? Vamos passar. A gente vai Voltar Ali De Alguns Passos.
E vai andar principalmente a parte do converge como um todo. E aí a gente vai indo e a gente Vai Tentando Debugar Isso Aqui Beleza.
Beleza. Vou botar todo mundo no Mute para a gente começar.
A gente tem muita coisa.
Muita gente para matar em pouco tempo.
Beleza, pessoal. Bem, sejam muito bem vindos ao segundo dia do nosso Boot Camp.
Onde a gente está trabalhando literalmente a criação. Fim a fim.
De uma fábrica andando por cada dia, pensando nas lentes de diferentes profissionais, para a gente entender exatamente esse conceito De Ai Native Engine.
E hoje a gente vai olhar um pouquinho a lente de um tradutor.
Como que, literalmente.
A gente vai se comportar como solutions. Na verdade, um software Engineer.
Para entender o problema que a gente tem em relação a isso. E como a gente vai operar nele.
Já ver um pouquinho do que a gente viu ontem. E a gente vai navegar nesses caps.
Então, hoje a gente vai fazer um recap. A gente vai passar um pouquinho no conceito de Agent Harness, que é Algo Extremamente Interessante Que A Gente Precisa Saber.
Principalmente sobre as últimas atualizações que têm acontecido no mercado.
A gente vai falar um pouquinho de como utilizar a ontologia e, literalmente, o Second Brain para poder ajudar a gente a entender.
Essa transpilação. Essa tradução que a gente vai fazer para uma nova indigning que a gente precisa fazer de acordo.
Com as tarefas que a gente recebeu.
E a gente vai ver um debriefing ali do que vai acontecer no próximo dia. Beleza.
Então a gente vai passar aí na lente de um software Engineer.
E a gente vai criar uma engine completamente nova do zero, para poder, literalmente fazer a tradução desses arquivos, lembrando Que A Gente Vai Rodar Dois Processos Em Paralelos Aqui.
Então. Bem, o que a gente viu ontem? O que a gente falou ontem, né? Então, a primeira coisa que A Gente Viu Ontem Né Foi Literalmente.
Verificar aqui. O sistema já nos proporcionava.
Uma forma de validar o sistema legado. Então o sistema legado é maduro.
O sistema legado já existe. O sistema legado é estável. Entretanto, o que a gente entendeu ali, em todos os E Mails Informações E Que A Gente Vai Fazer Uma Situação.
Mas antes dessa migração, a gente vai ter esses caras rodando em paralelo. Então não vai ser simplesmente um replace. Vai ser.
Um novo sistema, uma nova perna que a gente vai criar uma perna mais moderna. Para isso.
E a gente viu que existe um Steel Thread, que é o que eu falei para vocês, que é o Mínimo Viável Para A Construção De Alguma Coisa.
Que é literalmente um make run.
Com o tipo um para validar que aquele valor literalmente bate só para a gente recapitular.
O que a gente falou desse número? Bater, né?
A gente. O que que a gente viu no tipo? Um que é um dos tipos dos de arquivos que A Gente Vai Trabalhar A Gente Vai Trabalhar Com Cinco Tipos Essa Semana.
O que a gente viu claramente é que.
Dentro desse arquivo. A gente tem o header. A gente tem um detalhe. A gente tem um trailer.
Então, dentro do detalhe daquele arquivo, você pode ter uma soma de diferentes transações que acontecem, e a soma dessas transações.
Elas precisam bater. O trailer precisa ser certo. Só que existe uma complicação aqui.
And. A gente tem que fazer essa validação existe Cobal Overpunch, que é exatamente quando você troca uma sigla ou Um Caráter Especial Por Um Valor.
Dentro do cobol, que ele equivale a diferentes ou mais positivo ou negativo.
Tá? Então uma das coisas que a gente vai olhar lá.
Dentro do arquivo. Entender. A gente navegou sobre isso ontem, e a gente vai continuar navegando sobre isso hoje.
Lembra que a grande ideia é você ter bastante paciência.
E entrar no Flow e se sentir desconfortável, porque é difícil.
Né? A gente entendeu um caso de uso, literalmente um dia. Então a ideia é, se você criou.
O nosso Gemini Notebook. O nosso notebook com o filme de Pain.
A ideia é que você passe. Eu sei que o dia corrido, mas pô.
A gente começa às oito horas da noite, justamente para vocês poderem ter ali meia hora, quarenta minutos, talvez uma hora.
No dia para vocês poderem dar uma pesquisadinha. Sabe, tirar dúvidas. Enfim.
A ideia do notebook. Lm: é justamente para isso. Então a gente pode usar ele como nosso Second Brand Projeto, para perguntar.
Dúvidas que a gente tem.
A gente vai passar aí por uma série de tipos de arquivos. Então a gente colocou isso dentro do notebook Llm Para Poder Fazer.
Perguntas e ter citações de respostas naqueles documentos para a gente validar a acurácia disso.
A gente viu também a camada de ontologia com Ontolayer, para poder validar exatamente o que significa a informação.
De uma definição de uma tabela, de a definição de um install procedure.
Mas no contexto da onde do domínio. Então lembra que a camada ontológica diferente de um século de Brain, o Second De Brain Basicamente é O Quê.
So pega um bocado de documento.
Você bota um local, e aí você usa uma Lm para fazer perguntas.
Essas informações, elas podem estar simplesmente dentro de um repositório no Github.
Elas podem estar dentro de um projeto no codec ou no Cloud.
Ou ele pode estar dentro, por exemplo, do notebook llm Lm: Uma das vantagens do notebook. Lm.
E depois debaixo dos panos. Todos os documentos que você coloca aqui.
Ele indexa. Isso via Regg.
Então, qual é a grande sacada aqui? Você consegue ter muito fácil essas referências. De onde ele achou essas informações. Isso é Muito útil Para A Gente.
Porque diz a acurácia e a veracidade daquela informação? Truth.
Então isso é uma coisa muito importante para a gente poder trabalhar literalmente, confiar ao longo do tempo.
So inicialmente você pergunta valida até que você ganhe um nível de confiança de saber que as perguntas que você está fazendo.
São realmente alinhadas com o documento e com as versões do documento.
Que faz então? Assim, eu particularmente nos meus projetos, eu já utilizei muito codecs.
Eu já usei muito cloud. Eu já usei muita, muita coisa.
Mas mais efetivo do que o notebook. Lm: Para isso eu não conheço. Tá de longe. Ele é muito efetivo.
Não só por causa disso, mas porque você pode aqui dele, derivar várias coisas interessantes aqui do projeto, né?
Você pode criar quiz. Você pode criar flat para livrar. Você pode criar infográfico.
Você pode transformar isso no slide deck. Você pode transformar isso no áudio. Você pode transformar isso num podcast num mapa mental.
Então a flexibilidade que você tem de entender. Aquela informação é muito interessante dentro do notebook. Lm: Então.
Eu recomendo demais que você tenha ali sua base, né?
Então aqui você pode ter seus projetinhos e divididos ele por, né? Por projetos, por clientes. Enfim.
E você tem uma base. Você pode compartilhar essa informação também. Então você pode fazer um bocado de coisas interessantes.
Aqui dentro. Beleza.
Beleza.
O que a gente tem aqui, né?
A gente tem, então a camada ontológica, como eu falei para você. A diferença é que a ontologia vai olhar Para Dentro Das Suas Bases De Dados Suas Fontes De Dados.
E a partir disso, ela vai criar uma indexação inteligente. Ela vai criar glossária. Ela vai criar.
Descrição vai criar significado em cima dessa informação. Em cima dessas tabelas.
Elementos para que os agentes consigam entender relações. Por exemplo, poxa aonde eu acho tal informação. Então você pode construir Um Lineage A Partir Disso.
Sabe, por exemplo, que você tem uma tabela staging que tem uma store procedure.
Que escreve essa informação em outro local.
Então a camada ontológica te ajuda com isso também.
A gente viu rapidamente. A gente vai exatamente navegar hoje.
No converge aonde a gente vai capturar esses documentos. E a gente vai transformar esses documentos num.
Processo técnico. Um documento técnico, tá? Eu acredito que existe um processo canônico de como nós construímos qualquer tipo de coisa.
Por exemplo, se a gente olhar aqui, o Arp Factory.
Na verdade, eu estava trabalhando justamente para algo parecido com o que o Arp lançou, né?
Que é o Arp Factory, que é o primeiro software realmente que eu vejo que faz isso. Basicamente, o que O Harp Factory Faz Né.
Ele é uma fábrica de software.
Que aceita Requests. E aí pode ser Bug feature.
Escalação ou qualquer coisa. E basicamente, o que ele vai fazer é cara.
Destrinchar isso numa fábrica.
Em que ele vai conseguir executar isso de forma nativa para você.
Então por quê? Porque isso é canônico. Ou seja, o que é ser canônico. Isso é padrão. Você tem uma Requisição Você Tem Alguma Coisa No Meio Fazendo Isso E Você Tem Um Resultado Que Sai.
Obviamente que isso era impossível fazer antigamente, sem sistemas agênticos, mas hoje, completamente.
Possível e factível da gente. Criar.
Então converge. A gente vai passar por várias coisas que aconteceram, né?
Desde a intenção até o Spec. Hoje, a gente vai analisar.
Basicamente dezassete do Converge e dos componentes que ele tem. Então a gente vai ver isso, tá?
E a gente vai ver principalmente a parte do consenso e das questões que vão acontecer.
O que a gente viu ontem. De interessante, né? Então, olhando um pouquinho os transcripts, o transcript sempre vai estar Disponível Se Você For Lá.
Na verdade, no repositório, tem uma passe de transcripts. Já existe transcript de ontem. Então.
Até meio dia. Eu publico isso para vocês, tá.
E aí a gente falou de algumas coisas importantes aqui, né?
Primeiro, a gente não consegue garantir que as regras para um agente são determinísticas como que a gente consegue fazer Isso Existem Várias Formas De Você Fazer Isso Via.
Texto ou via prompt.
Mas a única forma realmente de você garantir isso aqui.
é você literalmente fazer o quê? O binding que a gente vai falar um pouquinho sobre isso hoje, tá, então Essa é A única Forma De Você Garantir.
Que o seu Hardness vai seguir o binding específico. E eu vou explicar sobre isso, tá.
A gente também viu alguns erros de Sftp que aconteceram. Interessante para a gente poder.
Debugar. Entender como isso aplica em todos os tipos de níveis de máquina. A gente viu que isso está vinculado Muito Mais Ao Ssh Que Você Gere O Non Host Que Possivelmente Você Não Tenha.
Então ele gera um problema e não deixa fechar o Taekwan. A validação. A gente passou por esse problema ontem, né?
E a gente falou também um pouquinho do Open router para ser uma boa opção para a gente.
Que é utilizar e testar novos novos.
Novos modelos, Egy? Ou literalmente, né?
Testar certas novas coisas.
Falamos bastante do notebook. Lm: A importância e falamos também do Second Brain, né?
Algumas coisas legais.
A gente colocou aqui, né? Alguém colocou que a persona do arqueólogo é cavar e cavar cada vez mais.
Então é exatamente isso que a gente queria entender ontem, como um arquiteto de soluções como ai engineer é literalmente Olhar Dar Um Passo Para Trás Trezentos E Sessenta Fit.
E olhar essa informação.
A gente também viu que foi possível que um modelo.
Free conseguiu executar muito bem essa tarefa. E aí cada vez mais, a gente vai ver ao longo desses dias, né?
A importância.
De você declarar unidades pequenas de trabalho, e cada vez mais a gente vai ver. Por exemplo, se você olhar um pouquinho.
Como as Llms se comportam hoje.
Eu lembro um pouquinho, que é uns sete, oito meses atrás, existia.
Uma conversa muito grande no mercado que falava o seguinte.
Falava bem. A tendência do mercado é a gente. Ir para o quê? Para modelos especializados.
Então, teoricamente, você teria um modelo de Python.
O modelo ou o modelo de programação, um modelo de assim por diante. Isso, existem algumas nuances hoje.
Mas o que a gente vê na verdade, é esse trabalho sendo feito para quê? Por diferentes subagentes.
Então o sub agente desempenha essa ideia de você conseguir acessar.
Partes específicas.
Do seu modelo certo? Do seu processo. O que eu quero dizer com isso?
Eu estou querendo dizer com com isso para vocês o seguinte: pô.
Imagina.
Imagina aqui que.
Você está olhando ali como um todo. E você pede, cara, escreva para mim uma aplicação em Python.
Beleza. Outra coisa é falar o seguinte. Olha.
Assinala um agente especialista em Python.
Que tem sete anos de experiência, que possui essas características, que.
Trabalha com. Com o código paitônico que utiliza design Patterns e assim por diante.
Então, se o código vai ser muito mais bem direcionado e muito mais bem escrito, tá? Então a ideia é a gente conseguir.
Separar com isso. A gente viu o Brief Spec, né? Que está disponível para vocês.
Que basicamente ajuda nessa interface. Do que ele vai cuspir, do que ele vai falar e assim por diante. Tá.
Beleza. O que. Que. Aonde foi que a gente parou ontem, né? Ontem, lá no finalzinho da aula, para quem ficou.
O que a gente fez na verdade, é passar pelo converge.
Nos primeiros passes. Eu chamo de pes.
O pé é o pes relacionado à captura.
Então o que a gente fez na verdade, né.
A gente pegou todas as informações que foram enviadas para a gente dentro do repositório. Dentro do contexto, como um todo.
E a gente injetou dentro do primeiro passe do Converge.
Para ele. Fazer o quê? Para ele pegar esse bando de documento.
E ele criar para a gente um documento inicial de business, requirement document.
Então a ideia era geralmente gerar esse documento de captura, com todos os detalhamentos do que seria literalmente a escrita do tipo um.
Do chord settlement.
E daí o passe um, literalmente, que era captar a intenção.
Essa intenção. Vai fazer o quê? Ela vai olhar o arquivo.
E ela vai compilar essa informação dentro de um documento técnico para a gente avaliar.
Então a gente vai ver eles logo mais e a gente vai navegar com cada passo do Converge. Hoje também.
é.
Olha só. O Wilker falou uma coisa legal aqui. Utilizei a Task Spec no Cloud para criar tarefas para o Jean Code Foram Dezenove Tarefas E O Jean Executou Todas Corretamente Melhor Na Avaliação Do Cloud.
E de fato, fez o que eu precisava.
Exatamente por quê? Porque segue aquela premissa do que a gente falou, né? A ideia de pegar uma coisa muito Grande E Conseguir Transformar Ela Numa Unidade Atômica De Trabalho.
Então isso vai fazer com que você não só consiga ter muita precisão no que você execute.
Mas também te traz a ideia de você ter a ideia do multi harness. Isso ajuda você.
A conseguir executar em dines diferentes aqui.
Para fazer esse processo, tá.
Beleza. Então a gente vai basicamente começar olhando um pouquinho para trás do que a gente fez no dia anterior.
A gente vai acessar o repositório. A gente vai ver um pouquinho do make status novamente.
E a gente vai dar uma olhadinha no Brd e no Spec que a gente criou.
Literalmente para começar, esse trabalho. Tá.
Antes disso, Eric, pode perguntar.
Deixa eu ver se tá? Acho que eu consigo ver se consegue.
Acho que deu certo.
Mhm.
Sobre a toxicidade particularmente eu, não sei se tu vai, chegar nisso.
Esse detalhe mais à frente.
Como tu conseguiu definir, essa atomicidade. Na decomposição.
Do teu, documento técnico.
Eu divido ela em duas coisas. Primeiro, conseguir decompor a um nível que fique fácil de gerar uma tarefa. Então Isso é O Sim Wise Que Faz Esse é O Primeiro Pedaço.
Quando eu tenho algo muito grande.
O Task Spec não vai fazer muito bem esse trabalho de olhar para uma coisa muito grande e tentar adiar.
O que ele vai fazer. Basicamente, vão ser várias suposições.
Por isso que eu criei o Sinwise. é exatamente esse processo. Antes da especificação da tarefa.
Então eu vou fazer primeiro a decomposição do problema.
E depois eu vou colocar ele já de uma forma com que ele fique muito fácil de você entender. Quais São As Características Técnicas Em Cima Disso.
E a atomicidade basicamente significa o quê? O tudo ou nada. No final do dia.
Então eu vou abrir um Work Tree. Eu vou executar uma tarefa completamente.
E eu vou olhar para as validações que eu tenho dentro dessa tarefa. Se todas as validações estiverem verdes e.
O Card que eu vou falar também estiver aceito. Então, essa tarefa é marcada como completada.
Se eu tiver n tipos de interação ou um budget de x dólares, e eu não conseguir bater em relação A Isso Então O Que Eu, Faço.
Eu faço um rollback, o que é basicamente destruir aquele Work Tree.
Então eu tenho exatamente esse conceito de atomicidade. Via Work Tree.
Então aqui, ó, vamos lá. Dentro do repositório.
Que foi atualizado alguns minutinhos atrás.
A gente vai vir aqui em Run.
E aqui a gente vai vir.
Nu D dois.
Beleza. E aqui a gente tem basicamente toda a explicação que a gente vai fazer. Quais são as relações? Enfim.
Quais são os bits que a gente vai executar e assim por diante. A gente vai pegar aqui o prompt status, né?
Então o primeiro.
Prompts que a gente vai executar aqui. Na verdade, dentro do ambiente. é o seguinte.
Vou mudar nenhum arquivo. A gente vai rodar um make status para abrir aquela evidência que a gente executou.
Para verificar se as coisas estão funcionando do mesmo jeito do que ontem.
Então, o que esse processo vai fazer aqui? Na verdade, né.
Ele vai rodar uma evidência local.
Do ambiente legado.
Ou seja, Sftp.
Java Sftp.
Csv. Ele vai pegar esse arquivo. Ele vai copiar para dentro do Post. Com isso. Você vai ter uma procedure Que Vai Rodar Que Vai Cuspir Um Resultado.
Esse resultado tem que bater com o cartão, ou seja, com o contrato. Então o valor tem que bater corretamente.
Para eu saber que aquela informação ela está cem. Então, o que que a gente vai fazer.
Executar o make status. Faz exatamente essa garantia que a gente vai ter.
Esse tipo de validação. Então vamos abrir aqui.
O terminal, né?
E a gente vai executar esse cara.
Show só está reinicializando o meu super engineering. Aqui.
Para novos updates. Então a gente vai abrir aqui. ó.
Uma nova aba. Eu vou chamar essa aba de Endy to Endy que a gente vai executar hoje.
Grock. Quatro seis extra high.
Vamos então executar esse caso.
Verificar se a gente consegue executar.
Esse make status, né?
E o que que ele significa para a gente.
Beleza. Então ele vai de fato executar o que eu gosto, né? Na verdade. E aí eu tenho duas segregações no meu.
No meu dia a dia, tá gente, eu uso o Super Engineering.
Para quando preciso estar literalmente num cockpit, prestando atenção em cada.
Que a gente chama de turn a cada passada.
Eu gosto muito, né? De.
De investigar cada processo. Eu gosto de abrir, de ver qual o pensamento, até para eu começar a me acostumar Com Uma Llm Trabalha.
Então, para projetos que eu preciso estar aqui olhando, eu faço isso.
E para projetos que eu preciso de algo mais autônomo, eu utilizo Cmax, que é um terminal com interface de Terminal Que Me Traz Mais O Que Cara.
Esse é o objetivo. Executa. Eu não preciso ficar olhando toda hora. Eu não preciso ficar atento toda hora. Então muita gente me Pergunta Pô O que Você Usa O Supereneering Por Que Você Usa O Simax.
Não é a mesma coisa. Sim, no final das contas, é exatamente a mesma coisa. A diferença é que para O Meu Workload Aqui.
Eu tenho alguns. Algumas telas. Então eu divido de duas formas. Onde? Aqui eu tenho algo mais autônomo.
E aqui tenho algo que eu preciso prestar mais atenção que eu preciso literalmente.
Está atento.
Então é por isso essa diferença. Mas no final, faz a mesma coisa.
Beleza. Então, beleza, ele vai executar aqui o Make Run.
Então ele executou lá o Make Run.
Eu gerei evidência. A evidência está correta.
O valor que eu recebi do documento bate com o contrato. Bate realmente com o valor visto.
Então a gente consegue ver isso dentro do da pasta de evidência.
A evidência gerada dentro do arquivo chamado Reconciliation. Jason, que é esse cara aqui?
Então é exatamente isso que ele cuspiu aqui. Ele está lendo Reconciliation.
Então a gente teve literalmente o Matchet aqui, funcionando.
Vamos ver que a resposta que ele cuspiu.
Don't make status. Opa.
Hmm, interessante.
O status falhou no Rob Publisher.
Come aí. Isso. Entretanto, ele olhou, citava, batendo os números. A evidência está presente no micron.
Não está totalmente saudável.
O compouse mostra que o post fuz Stp estão funcionando.
Who make status falhou nas rolls do Sftp. Tipo um está batendo.
Mix status no Hippo.
Printou o seguinte problema. Então a gente tem aqui Runtime status failure.
Verified Sft Operation Field for Row. Rob Publish it.
Então, existe algum problema de roll aqui que foi identificado.
Então a gente pode, se a gente quiser abrir aqui o terminal.
It down make status.
E vê aqui. ó que eu tenho uma falha.
Verified Sftp Operation, Failed for Row Rob Publisher. A gente vai verificar exatamente aqui o que aconteceu.
Então health.
Aqui. Eu falhei. Olá.
Eu não tenho um rosto esquiar out.
Por algum motivo, eu não consegui executar perfeitamente. E fechar esse cara.
Recovery not attempted Historic verified sftp.
Related Deploy a provavelmente.
Porque antes da gente rodar um make Star, a gente tem que fazer um make deploy.
Quer fazer o deployment do ambiente como um todo, porque o meu falhou. Tá.
O meu falhou, porque, na verdade, hoje eu fiz uma atualização do Doc.
Na verdade, ele não tinha construído as últimas.
Botado de novo o ambiente. Tá vendo?
Então agora, quando eu botar de novo o ambiente, provavelmente quando eu fizer um make.
Staras agora eu não vou ter o problema da Roll.
Então tá aqui. Ela vai ser consertada.
Beleza. Então, por causa disso.
Gente perguntas pode. Não fiquem Shy. Não podem perguntar, tá? A gente tá indo junto aqui.
Uma das coisas que eu faço só para vocês entenderem. Eu não sei. Eu não sei.
O processo inteiro. Isso é intencional.
Eu deixo muita coisa aberta para a gente poder literalmente resolver juntos. Então não tem uma resposta de tudo. E Essa é A Ideia Realmente.
Então, quando eu gero aqui o run que vai ser dos dias.
Eu vou ter pedaços que não vai casar. Talvez às vezes a gente vai ter que fazer investigações.
I adicionais. Então o processo é esse mesmo, tá, então a ideia não é nada. Eu não fiz um rehearse Aqui Eu Não Testei Isso Aqui Ah Pô.
Afinal, eu criei a apresentação. Criei o processo como um todo. Sincronizei eles. Trabalhei na Llm, mas eu não testei fim. Enfim.
E a ideia é justamente para a gente poder fazer isso. Na perspectiva de alguém que está abordando isso.
De uma nova forma, tá.
Então eu quero que vocês entendam. Isso é importante.
Can you check that now.
Vamos verificar agora se a gente tem algum tipo de problema.
Make.
Status. O que a gente provavelmente não vai ter agora, porque eu fiz o Redeploy.
Ontem alguém teve problema com conversão Crflf Lf do que Windows da Sony Docker up. Estou com D um. Esqueci Que Fiz O Fork Tem Que Dar Um.
Force X do D dois e atualiza. E o repositório.
Que vocês vão ter acesso ao D dois.
Beleza.
Então o primeiro prompt foi esse. Segundo. A gente vai analisar os papéis. Os papers.
Então, antes de analisar os papers, a gente vai entender o que aconteceu ontem, né?
Então, só para a gente recapitular, vocês têm acesso ao converge. O que é? O converge.
Converge. E aí eu posso entrar aqui um pouquinho mais. Agora.
Ele é na verdade um Framework.
Que ele faz.
Ele entende a intenção. Ele faz a decomposição.
Ele faz a criação das atividades. Então ele utiliza na verdade, três mecanismos. Converge como master.
O Sim Wise para fazer a decomposição da tarefa. E o Task Spec.
Para, literalmente, criar a tarefa atômica.
Muita gente me pergunta, Luan, por que você dividiu isso em três produtos, né?
Big. Se a gente olhar, o convégio é muito grande, então ele vai servir muito para quando você quer criar O Que A Gente Quer Fazer Aqui.
Você quer, por exemplo, receber uma requisição, uma mudança. Você tem um processo que ele acontece numa cadeia e num Processo Seguido Então Por.
Eu recebo uma reunião. Eu entendo o problema do cliente. Eu pego isso. Eu transformo num requisito.
Desse requisito valida esse requisito. Eu quebro isso em várias estratégias dentro do repositório.
Depois o Ps para executar em pequenas atividades. Então você tem um processo contínuo.
Então converge. Ele funciona justamente para eu ter esse processo fim a fim.
Entretanto, como ele é muito grande.
O que eu entendi é que existem coisas separadas aqui. Muito bem. Por exemplo.
Eu uso Simwise para todos os projetos que eu trabalho.
E, por exemplo, no Datasip.
Que muita gente está aqui assistindo, inclusive quem é do Dataship, que é meu programa de mentoria. Fala eu aqui Só Para Eu Saber.
Eu vejo algumas pessoas aqui, mas só para saber quantas pessoas estão aqui assistindo.
Tem uma galera boa.
Então a gente trabalha lá em quatro projetos open sources, o Apex. Vamos ver se eu consigo lembrar de todos Eles Né O Apex Sentinel Oter E Agents Spec.
Então a gente existe? Podes ali. Na verdade.
Times trabalhando, que a gente chama de Cruise.
Trabalhando. E a gente tem hipóteses nesses times. Eles trabalham todos os projetos que eu trabalho aqui. Eu corto. Ele.
Eu faço a decomposição do que é a necessidade para o requisitos dos exames sinuais que a gente já vê hoje.
E o Task Spec, que é literalmente a decomposição da tarefa. Esse cara está muito mais à frente de todos Os Outros Como Um Todo.
Porque, na verdade, eu já trabalho com ele um bom tempo. E aí a gente depois trabalha nessa ideia.
Então o que a gente executou ontem, né? Ontem a gente executou uma Skill que o converge. Uma vez que você instala, faz.
Que ele justamente faz uma coisa que eu tenho muito problema. Tinha muito problema constante. Eu entrava numa reunião.
O cara mandava ali. Eu pegava o transcript da reunião, por exemplo. Essa é a ideia do primeiro passe. Aqui Tá Idea To Brd.
Então, só para vocês entenderem qual é a intenção dessa Skill? Aqui? Tá.
Essa Skill segue. Todas as Skills. Seguem as melhores práticas do mercado. São extremamente otimizadas assim por diante. Tá.
Tem o Front Matter tem tudo em cima dela.
Mas a Skill, basicamente o que ele faz, né?
Essa é a ideia.
Então ele faz um On Ramp.
O que é um Ramp? Ele vai tentar entender. Basicamente o seguinte. Eu vou pegar para aí. Eu vou pegar. Vou Mandar Slack Para Ele.
Vou mandar documento para ele. Vou mandar Md. Vou mandar Pdf. Vou mandar um transcript. Por exemplo, eu vou falar Para Ele O Seguinte Olha.
Executa o passo zero. Então, automaticamente, tem que ser Skill. Ela vai fazer.
Ela vai transformar ideias.
No briefing. Então é isso que ele vai fazer.
Ele vai transformar ideias em um briefing.
Da forma com que eu passo essas requisições. Todos esses documentos para ele que a gente viu ontem. A gente Tem Uma Série De Documentos Do Projeto.
E basicamente, a responsabilidade dele.
é literalmente pegar isso automaticamente, sem falar nada.
E criar uma estrutura documental.
Então, como que eu faço isso? Eu faço isso em três camadas. Não só para vocês entenderem hoje, como todos Os Sistemas De Hardness Funcionam.
Então eu vou abrir aqui.
In private.
Vou abrir aqui.
Um Boot Camp. E aí eu vou compartilhando essas cenas com vocês no Boot Camp. Tá.
Então, como que a gente faz, né?
Então aqui você tem você como usuário.
Vamos pegar aqui. Você usuário.
Você vai.
Interagir.
Via chat.
Então você tem uma interface de chat para interagir.
Esse chat. Ele chama um Llm.
Certo? Esse chat. O que ele faz, né?
Ele chama.
Quando você está utilizando converge, né? Então eu quero utilizar o converge. Aqui é o converge, por exemplo.
Converge.
E aí você fala bem? Estou utilizando converge.
Estou utilizando converge aqui. Tá, instalei ele. Estou utilizando converge.
Então eu faço uma pergunta para o chat.
Beleza. O Chat.
Tem uma Lm invocada.
Esse chat. Vai.
Chamar uma Skill.
E essa Skill vai chamar uma cli.
Então, basicamente, isso que vai acontecer.
Então isso tudo aqui é o quê? Você poderia chamar isso aqui?
De.
Center Back.
Vamos tirar aqui.
Podemos deixar clarinho para ficar, nos deixar assim.
Eu passo para vocês, tá.
Achar bem claro.
A gente pode chamar isso aqui.
De Agent Harness.
Que é o que.
Isso é um Hardness.
Beleza. Então muita gente às vezes não consegue entender a sequência. Essa é a sequência para você entender.
Para você transformar a experiência de um sistema genético num hardness.
Então eu tenho você fazendo uma pergunta via chat.
Que está instalado com vestin. Cara. Eu utilize um. Converge o primeiro passo.
Ele vai entender. Vai carregar Skills.
Vai chamar Clai. E a Clay vai literalmente fazer o quê? Vai pegar todas essas informações junto com a Llm, E No Final Vai Dar Um Gate De Paz Falando Check Brd.
Tipo: cara. Peguei todas essas informações e transformei num documento.
Literalmente resumido. Vamos ver a qualidade desse documento.
Então, basicamente, o que a gente fez ontem, né? Ontem, a gente supriu esse cara com as informações.
De documento. Então, se a gente olhar aqui em Run.
D um.
E a gente via aqui dentro do capture, que é o primeiro.
Que é o Pé zero.
O que a gente fez. Na verdade, a gente pegou um prompt falando simplesmente o seguinte: olha.
Pega todos os documentos que estão dentro de docs Brd settlement.
The Second Brain the State. Enfim, ingere ele dentro.
Dentro desse cara. Basicamente é isso. Utiliza o passe zero.
E pega e insere esses documentos.
Eu não precisaria explicar tudo isso que eu precisaria fazer. é simplesmente.
Use o passe. Capture para ingerir dessa pasta desse documento.
E olha só o que ele fez, né? Então, uma vez que a gente fez isso, ele veio aqui em Docs.
E ele criou um Brd.
Type one card settlement.
Tá.
Calma, baby. Shark.
Brincadeiras à parte, a gente não gera, Abrs. Gente primeiro gera um business. Requirement document.
E disso vai ser gerado. Adrs: na verdade, vai ser gerado um documento técnico.
Depois desse documento técnico, vai ser gerado, Adrs. E a gente vai entender por quê. Tá.
Então a gente está destrinchando o processo ainda mais de fora para dentro.
Então aqui o que ele fez, cara, ele criou um puta documento.
Fantástico, tá? Quem perguntou?
O que realmente nós temos. Qual é o processo como um todo?
O que significa, Donn, né.
Qual é a mentira? Qual que possa ser a mentira realmente? Dos valores que não batem que a gente viu. Pode acontecer.
De chegar a documentos que não batem de chegar arquivos que não batem com a realidade. A gente viu, por exemplo, um exemplo.
A gente falou um pouquinho do que é documento, do que é literalmente o que é o certo e o que não é.
O que a gente vai fazer.
Sumário executivo. Qual é o problema? Então, o que que exatamente foi pedido.
Foi pedido para a gente. A Helena pediu para a gente reconstruir os cinco tipos de arquivos que nós temos.
Numa nova arquitetura que a gente vai construir hoje juntos, né?
Que basicamente, garantir que a gente consegue executar esse cara fora de uma outra. Engine Modern.
E aqui ele explica um pouquinho do problema, né?
Então Park não existiu. Fire Overnight Files. Então a gente ainda tem Partner jogando arquivos no final da noite para Java.
Para fazendo tudo isso. A Helena Drop um e mail falando sobre essas informações como o Java funciona, o que Significa Correto Medida Assim Por Diante.
O problema não é que o Java é muito velho. O problema é que o Source Unit.
Então a fonte realmente muda.
Tá? E essas informações devem estar visíveis.
Além disso, a gente tem uma forma melhor de como tratar esses arquivos. Tá.
A gente tem os objetivos aqui, né?
Que nós temos o escopo. O que está fora, o que não foi decidido.
Qual a definição de sucesso? Stakeholders, riscos. E aí, o que é uma coisa legal? Aqui tá.
Em algum momento desse converge, a gente vai passar por um Grill Main.
Um processo onde ele vai começar a perguntar.
Para vocês. Se você tem um entendimento correto.
Desse processo, para que você possa fechar esse entendimento entre a máquina.
A gente não vai conseguir ir para frente se a gente não tiver isso.
Então ele gerou esse documento. Deixou algumas perguntas abertas aqui, que provavelmente a gente vai passar por elas. Tá.
Indicou quais são as fontes.
Quem foi que fez? O Walner decide qual foi a data que a gente fechou isso. Enfim.
Então a gente jogou um bocado de coisa para eles, e ele gerou esse documento, então, bem, bem decente. Então A Primeira Coisa Que Ele Fez.
Foi exatamente isso. Voltando aqui.
Vamos voltar aqui para a lista de.
De atividades do Run.
Então, se a gente voltar aqui no Run.
D. Dois.
Prompt Papers. Então eu gerei esse primeiro documento.
Que aconteceu aqui? A ideia.
E agora, qual o próximo passo do converge, né.
Ele vai transformar um business. Requirement document.
Para um requisito técnico. Então a segunda Skill que eu tenho aqui.
é uma Skill que vai fazer o quê? Ele vai transformar um arquivo.
Em, literalmente algo mais técnico.
Então ele vai começar a destrinchar essas informações.
Com uma clareza mais técnica do que significa. Ele vai olhar repositório, verificar o que você já tem. Ele vai.
Que irá escopos de exemplo e assim por diante. Então, o que ele fez aqui.
Exatamente isso. A gente vê, né?
Então, se a gente vier aqui, na verdade, nesse documento, deixa eu abrir ele aqui.
To the inbox Tech Spec. Tá aqui.
Então a gente transformou lá o Techs Pack. Na verdade, o business requirement documents num tech pack, né?
Então aqui ele explica um pouquinho agora do problema. Mas com a lente do quê? Agora, com a lente técnica, né?
Então, o que está no escopo? O tipo um. O que está fora do escopo, tipo seis.
Substituiu Java editar a linha. Quais são os requisimentos? Quais são os Must? Está vendo.
Foi o que ele já começam a trabalhar os requisitos, né?
O que deve ser implementado.
O que poderia ser implementado, o que não será implementado.
Quais são as métricas de sucesso.
O que define isso?
O que foi nomeado.
Quais são as verdades que nós temos aqui? Quais são as fontes de dados? Tá.
O que é essa nova perna que a gente vai criar não deve fazer.
Ela não deve substituir o Java. Ela não deve editar legado contrato. Jane, ela não deve reparar programas que já existem.
Ela não deve tratar Spec como contrato, porque é um bocado de documento que chega.
Ela não tem que tratar os artefatos como um drop no Sftp. E aqui a gente tem algumas perguntas também Abertas Que A Gente, Vai Chegar Em Algum Momento Que A Gente Não Vai Conseguir.
Passar, tá? Mas olha só o que ele fala no Blocker S Gap is left pending.
Normally this block two nights out to it past two must not consume this draft as canonical.
Então, basicamente, ele fala. Olha no passe dois. A gente não vai consumir isso como se fosse a fonte da verdade.
A gente vai na verdade, inteirar em cima disso.
Então, o que a gente fez ontem foi exatamente gerar esses dois papéis aqui.
Que são os inícios do nosso processo.
Agêntico. Então, o que a gente vai fazer aqui agora, né?
A gente vai.
Vim aqui.
Vai ver, por exemplo, que agora a gente tem a role.
Então está tudo certo, Donny. Tudo bonitinho.
E agora a gente vai ver o seguinte: leia o documento de business. Requirement document.
E o documento técnico tá. E aí traz algumas informações para a gente.
Então, o que isso difere do Agents Spec Eric, por exemplo.
Não muita coisa. Se a gente for olhar um pouquinho.
Mas a gente pega. A gente tem um processo um pouco mais.
Eu vou desengessado. Talvez.
Porque o Spectrum Development vai me ingessar um pouco mais pelas características. Aqui a gente vai ter algo um pouco mais. Open scope.
Mas você vai ver que no final, vai transbordar exatamente para a mesma linha de um Spectrum Development.
Ideia é que, ao longo do processo do converge, a gente vai captando intenção e vai entendendo algumas coisas importantes.
Então, olha só. Que interessante que eu pedi aqui.
Quem perguntou. Então, Helena, o que está fora do escopo.
Qual é a mentira? Basicamente, o que a gente acabou de ler, né? O que tem que ter, o que Não Tem Que Ter.
Quais são as evidências? De onde vêm essas informações?
Então a primeira coisa como um Ai Nietzsche Engineer é passar tempo lendo é passar tempo, entendendo.
Então, se a gente fosse fazer tudo isso sem as Skills e sem o Conve, a gente passaria semanas aqui.
Então a ideia de você ter Skills é justamente para poder minimizar.
Ou canonizar. Eu diria que é transformar algo que é repetitivo.
Em algo que você pode utilizar constantemente. E aí você vai criar uma planta disso, né? Um blueprint.
Para você utilizar em vários casos. Então essa é a grande ideia.
é você facilitar o seu trabalho.
E parar de ser repetitivo. é basicamente isso. No final do dia.
Deixa eu parar aqui. Alguma dúvida? Perguntem.
Para começar a ficar cada vez mais complexo. Então.
A gente. Precisei entender. Pode perguntar, Marco.
Ah, Luan. Tudo bom.
Billy.
Church, deixa eu te perguntar.
Pergunt.
Hoje. Eu rodeio.
Toda essa parte aí do.
Da Dark Factory. E, por exemplo, depois que eu cheguei na tarefa concluída.
Eu descobri que eu tinha esquecido de passar, por exemplo, um.
Um certificado para poder rodar. E eu tive que rodar tudo.
Novamente. Se nesse momento, aí que você está rodando, um converge para poder passar por.
Swim. Para poder quebrar essa história, você precisa fazer um loop.
E votar um documento geralmente como que você faz isso?
Eu não volto no documento. Porque se você habilitar o Grill, me, a ideia é que você tenha vários questionamentos Antes De Chegar Mas Vamos Supor Que Naquele Requisito Você Passou Por Ele.
O que você pode fazer é fazer um refilling dentro do Cvg.
Você tem um refilling que basicamente você vai falar o seguinte. Olha, eu tenho essa parada que foi introduzida aqui no meio.
E daí o converge vai saber colocar no local certo para você. Se ele está dentro do business, requirement document. Se Ele Está Dentro Do Technical Requirement Document.
Se ele vai entrar dentro do Sim, se ele vai entrar dentro do Sim, então, automaticamente, ele vai saber fazer isso.
Você só pega o requisito e fala. Converge. Coloca isso no local correto para mim. E aí ele vai.
Vou fazer isso para você. Automático.
Pode perguntar. Diogo.
Diego.
Olan. Boa noite. Tudo bem.
Boa noite, beleza.
Eu só queria dar uns dois passos atrás. Uma coisa que eu fiquei em dúvida.
Você chegou a citar aqui no converge na criação.
Da Business Spec. Ele faz utilização lá do nosso Second Brain do Notebook. Lm.
Em que momento? Há uma configuração.
Do acesso do Converge ao notebook. Lm: para que ele possa ler.
No I don't no. O que eu faço é, ele tem um documento. Eu só apontei para o documento necessariamente Para O Notebook Lm.
Ah, você apontou para o documento que nós já temos. Ele no repositório.
Exatamente.
Mas eu me corrijo se eu estiver errado. Você chegou a citar que é possível utilizar um secure brain.
Na construção do Brd.
é se você quiser. Sim.
Se quiser. Assim, tem uma ski opcional aqui que você pode falar. Por exemplo, eu quero me conectar num Second Brain Tal Lugar E Daí Ele Vai.
Ou ele vai dentro. Por.
Envi a pena.
Isso.
Ou ele vai no Besidian, ou ele vai em algum outro lugar e busca essa informação pra você e tenta.
Eventualmente criar esse documento para você.
Isso.
Então é como se a gente desse várias fontes de acesso a documentos e dados em relação ao projeto, para O Converge Poder Criar O Brd Né.
Essa ideia. Certo.
Exatamente. Essa é a Ide.
Não, beleza. Obrigado. Valeu.
Nada. Valor.
Cá. Então, a gente avaliou esses documentos aqui. Beleza.
E agora o que a gente vai fazer, né?
Bem, entendemos que a gente gerou zero em um.
Então, só para a gente colocar todo mundo na mesma página.
Fizemos. Trouxemos várias ideias ou vários documentos que foram enviados para a gente como Time.
E transformamos isso num business. Requirement document.
E aí executei o Business Requirement document, para criar literalmente esse documento.
Que é um documento técnico.
Beleza. Então, o que a gente vai transformar quando eu executar a Fase dois?
Ele vai começar a fazer algumas quebradas para mim aqui, que a gente vai ver. Já já.
Então a gente vai andando aqui nessa cadeia.
De passos. Tá.
Então, hoje, o que a gente vai fazer.
Hoje, a gente vai olhar pela lente de um software Engineer.
Então lembra que a ideia aqui é vocês terem um pouquinho da ideia do que cada um.
Deveria desempenhar num processo desse, se a gente fosse olhar para uma forma um pouco mais.
Moderna de fazer é um Ai Natm Engineer, fazendo o trabalho de todo mundo, coordenando e orquestrando esses agentes. Para fazer isso.
Se fosse da forma anterior, seria eu como Solutions Architect, por exemplo, como eu já fiz durante muitos anos.
Desenhando a solução, desenhando o problema, criando os documentos e passando para a minha equipe técnica, como, por exemplo, engenheiro de software.
Então, falando na vida real, o que a gente está mostrando aqui, né?
A gente está mostrando que se fosse, por exemplo.
Tim, Wise.
Como seria isso aqui, né.
Seria basicamente.
Hmm. Sa um Solutions, Architect.
E daí a gente teria, né.
Aí um Swwe.
A gente teria. Olha só que loucura! Como que as empresas de consultoria vão lidar hoje com os problemas que Estão Chegando Aí Para Vocês Terem Ideia Da Dimensão.
Do negócio. Então seria um Swa que a gente precisaria para esse projeto.
A gente precisaria de um de. De um dear engineer.
A gente precisaria de um analytics engineer.
A gente precisaria de um Devops.
Com certeza. E a gente precisaria de.
Um ai engineer.
Então deixa eu botar Analytics aqui.
Em Devops.
Então como eu já fiz isso, né? Então eu.
Lá na pífia. Muitas das vezes, quando eu vou fazer um trabalho, um projeto. Eu não gosto muito. Tá.
Mas quando eu vou fazer um projeto que envolve somente eu ser um arquiteto de solução, o que eu não gosto de ficar.
Fazendo Esse Trabalho Muito O Que Eu Tenho Que Fazer Pô Eu Tenho Que Criar As Documentações Eu Tenho Que revisar o plano. Eu tenho que criar o escopo, enfim, ir lá para o meu time e falar cara para esse projeto. Aqui a Gente Tem Um Conversor De Java Para Python Preciso De Um Engenheiro De Software Para Fazer Isso.
O engenheiro de dados não vai conseguir fazer isso. Muito bem, pô, eu preciso criar um pipeline de dados.
Literalmente a cópia de um banco de dados relacional.
Para um delware housing, por exemplo. Ou eu chamo o Dead Engineer.
Pô. Agora eu preciso criar toda a camada de bronze sever, principalmente na Gold, pra ver o que o cliente precisa, né?
Qual o relatório que ele vai consumir. Quais são as informações que ele vai consumir? Daí eu uso um Analytics Engineer.
Pô beleza. Mas agora eu preciso construir uma base de reggae em cima disso. Eu preciso prover.
My Api para o cliente, por exemplo. Então eu vou chamar um ai Engineer. Tá legal. Mas eu preciso fazer o Deployment disso.
Agora, dentro de um ambiente de produção, deve Keyway, beleza. Preciso de um Devops.
Então, hoje, quando a gente olha para o processo normal, a gente está falando disso. Aqui.
Isso é o normal.
Mas basicamente, o que a gente vai fazer.
é pivotar cada vez mais.
Para esse modelo que vocês estão aqui vendo.
Então vocês estão literalmente.
Vendo um Glimpse do futuro, ou já está trabalhando um pouquinho dessa forma?
Então o Ai Native Engineer. O que que ele faz na verdade, né?
Ele na verdade, faz a mesma coisa.
Só que, ao invés.
De isso aqui. Ser.
Gerado por humanos.
E eu vou deixar aqui em vermelho. Por exemplo.
Isso aqui vai ser gerado por máquinas.
Interessante, né?
Eu acho bem interessante pensar sobre isso e ver.
Essa diferença, tá.
Eu acho muito foda chegar nessa conclusão. Eu lembro que.
Quando eu parei literalmente para pensar, falei: cara.
Beleza. A gente está saindo de um ambiente indo para o outro.
Então a gente para agora de falar com pessoas. A gente começa a passar isso para a máquinas.
E obviamente que a gente vai lidar com todo esse arcabouço aqui. De como isso é.
Diferentemente de lidar com humanos, que a gente já sabe um pouquinho melhor. A gente vai lidar com máquinas.
Mas aí você começa a ter um poder muito maior. Você começa a fazer o trabalho de cinco, seis pessoas, Sete Pessoas Oito Pessoas.
E se a gente não está falando nem da escala, né? Nem velocidade, nem escala, nem qualidade. A gente está Falando Só Em Relação às Rows.
Mas isso vai mudar também. Beleza.
Mas faz sentido só para eu parar aqui para ver se todo mundo entendeu.
Porque uma das coisas que vocês têm que mudar no boot camping não é só aprender técnico, vocês têm que Entender A Mentalidade Que Está Acontecendo No Vale Do Silício.
Está acontecendo nas expressas do país, e o que literalmente está transbordando aqui.
Facil para todo mundo. Coloca aqui no chat. Para mim.
Beleza.
Então a gente está indo muito mais para um modelo saindo de um modelo Teamwise, indo para um modelo de Ll Miwise.
Pode perguntar. Sebastião.
Luan. Hoje, inclusive.
Oi.
Um ex camarada que trabalhou comigo, me procurou exatamente com uma posição de Feedfall.
Só que ele trouxe o termo ainda builder. Porque além de fazer tudo isso agora, o pessoal ainda.
Desejo até que a gente crie algumas aplicações. Alguns sites, alguma coisa.
Então ele estava com esse papel. Se chegou até apresentar de.
Com um chapéuzinho de produto. Ele fez o desenho. Os requisitos todos do projeto. Já fez um.
Ali no Cloudfet. Criou uma visão. Falou Sebastião. Olha, agora eles têm que criar isso aqui. A ideia é criar Aqui Um Modelo De Growth é Uma Empresa De Marketing Que Entrega Todo Um Sistema De Loyalty Muito Grande Né.
E uni um Crm com o sistema de Loyalty em São Sebastião.
Preciso de uma pessoa agora. Porque com a eu vou ter vários desses chapéus. E eu sei que você consegue fazer isso.
Só que eu não sei se você já já chegou a trabalhar com o site, porque aqui a gente vai construir uma aplicação.
Então, como é que estava? Não sei. Mas eu posso descobrir como é que a gente faz. Porque agora, para Aprender é Dois Palito.
Então está até aumentando esse chapéus. Aí não é só mais para dados. Não.
Com certeza.
Beleza. Olha só como que a gente vai olhar isso no realm de um engenheiro de software. Como a gente Vai Abordar Isso Várias Coisas Que Fogem Do Nosso Conhecimento Pelo Menos Para Mim Se A Gente For Olhar.
O meu background, meu background. Muito sobre dados. Eu aprendi Python.
Alguns anos atrás, mas, na verdade, uma primeira experiência com linguagem de programação profunda. Mesmo foi com o Python.
Então eu tenho conhecimento zero de Java. Só sei que Java dá para passar no cabelo. Basicamente, tá.
Fora. Isso não serve absolutamente nada de Java. E está tudo certo.
Porque a gente tem hoje uma ferramenta extremamente poderosa.
E está nas mãos de quem digita.
Literalmente conseguir entregar algo no final ou não, que é você.
Então, como que a gente veste essa capa? A primeira coisa que a gente tem que fazer.
It's a ideia da gente driver.
E isso é uma coisa muito foda.
O que significa driver? Significa a gente estar no controle.
E está no controle. Não é você delegar cem do processo para a Llm.
Mas sim você pensar juntamente com ela.
Então o input tem que vir de você. Não o D. Llm. O que eu estou querendo dizer? Por isso.
Se você delegar a parte mais grossa e mais complexa do trabalho.
Eu vou falar uma coisa que muitas poucas pessoas falam.
Eu já escutei muita gente falando o seguinte.
Ah, mas é porque llm. Ela precisa de um input para poder fazer as coisas que eu quero.
Cara, se você parar para pensar um pouquinho.
Se você tem um Gpt, o Codec cinco seis sol, faz um teste.
That. Dá para ele um escopo assim bem ruim.
Cara. Eu quero construir uma aplicação. Java.
E tal tal tal Cria Um Plano Declarado Pra Mim De Quais São As Melhores Práticas Para Você Fazer Isso? Cara. Você vai ver, na verdade, que ele vai trazer um plano muito melhor do que você pensou. Ou do que você não idealizou.
Ele vai conseguir fazer isso? Muito melhor. Então, assim não é sobre a questão de você.
Pedir de forma crua. Mas é você de drive. é você estar literalmente como um comandante da sua frota de agentes.
Isso quer dizer o quê? Saber o que você pergunta. E quando você não sabe, você vai utilizar llm para Te Ajudar Para Idealizar Para Fazer O Idhaging Com Você Para Fazer Brainstorming Com Você.
Mas você está no comando. Sempre.
Não deixe de fazer esse processo, porque eu vejo muita gente hoje trabalhando com Llm, cara.
Sempre. Deixa lá, faz. é legal. Não revisa o plano. é isso aí que vai. No modelo automático de Wide Codes.
Você consegue construir até o final. Consegue.
Cara. Vão existir vários buracos no processo, assim como iria existir se você tivesse uma frota de pessoas trabalhando para você.
A diferença é que aqui você consegue.
Controlar. Isso é uma coisa importante. Você consegue controlar. E tem um outro problema, né?
Quem vai responder por isso? Não é o seu agente. é você. Então lembre disso que você precisa estar no controle, tá.
Outra coisa sempre seja baseado em evidência. Isso quer dizer o quê, cara, antes de você perguntar alguma coisa.
Tenha a informação. Entenda o que é que tem que ser perguntado.
Então simplesmente vai na Vibe, tá? Isso é muito importante. Tem evidência, primeiramente.
Depois conceitos sobre código.
Cara. Isso aqui é os fundamentos, né?
Então assim pô, eu não sei, Java. Então pô.
Cara em vez de eu literalmente abrir aqui o code base, pedir pra ele escrever. Será que não vale a pena? Vocês.
Cara. Dá um passo para trás e trabalhar com a Lime. Cara.
Eu tenho um projeto com Java. Eu estou aqui nesse projeto. Quero entender os básicos abstratos. Eu não entendo.
Pô. Quais são os conceitos principais? Desenhando um gráfico para mim? Coloca em estilo, tabela.
Me ensina sobre isso. Quais são as características.
Ensina. Para alguém realmente iniciante.
Qual que é a base no código, cara? Você vai estudar. Eu lembro que quando eu comecei a trabalhar lá para subsidiária da.
Os caras tinham code base inteiro. Ainda tem, né? Em Coatling, né? E eu não sei absolutamente nada de Coldling. Eu Não Sabia Nada De Coating Se Eu Não Sei De Java Imagina De Coldling Né.
E cara, eu comecei. é basicamente o que eu fiz é abrir o repositório.
Eu comecei literalmente a clicar, ver como que era o código. Assim, basicamente, olhar para o código.
Beleza. E daqui a pouco ir na Llm e falar pô beleza. Eu não tenho absolutamente nenhum conhecimento sobre Coltlin.
Poxa me. Explica antes de entrar no projeto. Me explica os principais blocos de coaching. Quais são os design pátrians que eu tenho.
Eu fui interagindo. Só que você não aprende isso em trinta minutos. Quarenta minutos. Você precisa de dias para digerir. Então, cara.
Você começa o primeiro dia. Você vai lá. Segundo dia. Você pergunta de novo. Daqui a pouco você começa a ver relação.
Que eu posso falar, cara, quero escrever um cara.
Extrai pra mim. Quais são os design paths desse repositório?
Aqui. Escreve num arquivo chamado Architecture por Md.
Pô escreveu: Pô. Agora eu vou criar um agente. Vou chegar pro Gpt e falar. Cara, eu quero construir um Novo Pedaço De Código.
Usa essa arquitetura como padrão e escreve para mim. Deixa eu validar.
Esse cara. E daí eu comecei a olhar. Falei: Pô, os códigos estão sendo gerados, basicamente iguais. Legal.
Pô. Compara esse código com outro. Então eu falei: Pô, Calma aí. Então eu tenho que pensar no seguinte. Um Escreve O Outro Revisa.
Cara. Quando eu fiz isso, eu comecei a escrever em três dias. Eu estava escrevendo código e eu não os Agentes Então Assim é Toda A Forma Como Você Aborda O Problema.
Então é muito importante que você entenda os fundamentos. Primeiro, passe tempo com isso.
Desenhe. Então, literalmente, faça o ideating com o Llm. Trabalhe com ela.
O Rafa fala muito porque ele não gosta de fazer muito essa parte com o Nlm. Gosta de fazer essa parte na cabeça.
cognitiva.
You are skipping SaaS.
para podefazizo.
Normamente.
Noisicia.
Umbrella.
Nijing…
Annaliste, vous dement umbrella de…
DBA, ves muta e umbrella geogue trabalundadas.
Et suggest foyadas.
Caro.
Tomcaraki…
Canal legal no Youtube, onde ele ensina sobre engenharia de software com ai.
E daí? Ele tem algumas coisas muito interessantes. Ele tem Skills que fazem isso. Se você olhar as Skills e Você For Pensar Um Pouquinho Como Ele Se Comporta.
Todas as Skills deles se comportam exatamente como o que eu estou ensinando aqui.
Que é você decompor algo muito grande para algo pequeno.
Então essa é a grande ideia. No final do dia.
Então, work as leaves, né?
Então a ideia é transformar isso num pedaço mais atômico possível.
Então, como tradutor, como translator, o que que você quer, né? Você quer entender os conceitos.
Você quer cortar o sistema de uma forma mais fácil de você literalmente entender.
Você quer entender que existe contratos e literalmente você quer criar e entender esse processo. Baseado nisso.
E o que você não quer literalmente, é criar uma solução completamente complexa. Então você quer reduzir complexidade e não adicionar complexidade.
E o que a gente vai fazer hoje, na verdade, é criar o Java to pie.
Que é o Java para Python. Então a gente vai fazer essa conversão.
E a ideia dessa conversão vem exatamente da conversa que nós tivemos.
Com o time da North Windpay.
Que é como que a gente vai conseguir traduzir esse sistema legado para uma nova perna moderna. E uma das Coisas Que A Gente Vai Fazer.
é trazer Python. A ideia da gente trazer Python. Existem várias.
Características aqui do porquê a gente vai fazer isso.
Primeiro que o Java é extremamente complexo de você trabalhar em grande escala na relação de dados.
é uma aplicação mais legada.
é uma aplicação que requer conhecimento específico. Então, o que a gente vai fazer é traduzir esse cara para a Gente Poder Escalar Para A Gente Ter Mais Facilidade De Escrita.
Para a gente ter uma integração melhor com o ecossistema de dados.
Então a gente vai fazer toda essa transmutação. A gente vai criar essa nova perna de Java para Python.
Beleza. Então a gente não vai substituir. Basicamente, o que a gente vai fazer hoje. A gente tem uma aplicação De Python Que Olha.
Lá pro Sftp lá para a pasta. Raw Incoming. A gente já fazia a mesma coisa.
Só que o Python vai olhar também para Rollin Coming cum.
E, diferentemente do que o Java vai fazer, de escrever em Csv como a gente já entende, já está preparado Para O Esquema De Dados Como Engenheiros E Como Times.
A gente não vai escrever isso em Csv porque não? é um dado otimizado para dado em grande escala. A Gente Vai Escrever Esse Dado Em Parquê.
Literalmente numa característica moderna.
E a gente vai começar a entender o seguinte. Bem.
Quais são as características.
Que esse sistema nos permite trabalhar.
Como que a gente pode pensar em como a gente consegue trabalhar. Uma arquitetura interessante para isso.
Deixa eu começar a desenhar um pouquinho isso agora.
Então, o que vai acontecer? São dois destinos diferentes mesmo Sftp.
Aqui pela perna do Java. A gente vai passar pelo Java.
Pelo Sftp de resultado final, escrevendo no post race.
E aqui o Python moderno. A gente vai mudar um pouquinho essa estratégia. A gente vai receber esse cara.
A gente vai colocar essa informação dentro do paquê.
E aqui, amanhã a gente vai ver a extensão dessa perna.
Tá beleza? Boa pergunta. Tá.
A Cíntia perguntou, a gente decidiu: você decidiu fazer isso? Via pelo requisito do cliente, ou você decidiu fazer isso justamente pelo nosso.
Bem o que a gente cita. Que ele precisa de um ambiente mais otimizado. Muitas das vezes, quando a gente Vai Entrar Nos Pormenores O Que A Gente Quer Fazer é Tentar Otimizar Cada Pedacinho Deles.
Por isso que quanto mais a gente entender, mais a gente vai conseguir.
Como Cinthia, a gente tem um background de dados. Então, para a gente, é muito.
é muito simples pensar que o output de algo que a gente faz para uma esteira de pipeline de dados.
Ela vai ter que ser autiputada de uma forma que seja otimizada. Então, na verdade, é uma coisa muito mais Que A Gente Vai Sugerir Como Time.
Como um ai, nem servir dinheiro do que, teoricamente, o cliente.
Muitas das vezes o cliente vai falar. Cara, qual é a dor que eu tenho.
E aí a gente vai decidir, tecnicamente, o que fazer com ela.
Beleza.
Beleza. Deixa eu parar um pouquinho aqui. Confesso que esse processo de gastar energia pensando no problema, é algo que Tenha Deixado De Lado Eu Também Tenho Deixado De Lado Muitas Das Vezes Então Relax.
Preciso criar esse hábito. Eu tenho cuidado de validar o output, coletar evidência, etc. Mas acredito que eu teria menos. Vai E Volta Com As Lms Se Eu Fizesse Esse Trabalho Anterior.
Essa é uma boa observação, Roger, que eu também cheguei nessa mesma observação.
Na verdade, eu tive uma observação. E eu lembro, tem um projeto específico que eu estava trabalhando.
Cara que eu gastei tanto, Turn, eu gastei tanta virada nele que eu falei, cara, será que não era melhor simplesmente eu entender.
Porque quando você não tem esse entendimento, cem, o que acontece é que a Ia começa a te levar para várias direções.
Então, se você ainda não consegue compilar a intenção, entender exatamente para onde está indo. Chega uma hora, por exemplo, Que Você Abre O Olho E Fala Caraca Calma Aí.
Mas era bem isso que eu queria fazer. Por exemplo.
Então é muito melhor você gastar Token no início.
Do que você gastar no meio ou no final, vai ser muito pior para você.
Então a ideia é você dar esse passo para trás e literalmente, passar tempo no início do projeto.
Compilando intenção, entendendo um problema, automatizando, vendo realmente o que é.
O projeto que precisa ser feito. Os componentes, como segregar, como fazer esse processo de criar cielis.
De criar o Harness. Então isso demora.
Mas depois que você consegue criar esse processo.
Aí. Você tem um processo contínuo muito maior, e você ganha na cauda longa.
Luan. Como que você organiza o raciocínio.
Uma linha de especificação quando você vê que foi para um lado errado. Mas em um momento.
Que você vai? Que você ainda não tinha chegado a ter feito uma Nova York. Tree quer voltar.
Em um ponto que você sabe que ainda estava legal. Qual o seu flow de trabalho nesse sentido ou raciocínio.
Então, antigamente, o que eu fazia? Na verdade, é. Eu anoto. Eu anoto algumas. Eu tenho algumas anotações que são Chaves Na Minha Cabeça Para Eu Lembrar.
Então, para cada projeto, eu tenho um notion que me diz basicamente o que eu quero construir, e a base Fundamental Do Processo Então Eu Guardo.
Isso como a minha intenção.
E isso é importante para eu voltar para lá. Por exemplo.
Eu vou dar um exemplo importante do que o Megaron falou. Aqui. Por exemplo, eu tenho um projeto chamado de.
Agents Context Protocol.
E basicamente, o que eu estou tentando determinar nessa pesquisa é criar um modelo de modelagem de dados que seja Eficiente Para Sistemas Agênticos.
Eu já estou trabalhando nele há uns três, quatro meses. Enfim.
Ele utiliza. Basicamente, ele rouba.
Ideias de todos os sistemas, de todas as modelagens. E aí eu uso uma combinação de data volt.
Com uma arquitetura. Medalhão com Kimball. Enfim.
Para poder escrever isso numa área em que eu consiga ter uma eficiência de tokens de entrada, saída e assim por diante.
E aí eu lembro que cara! Quando eu comecei o projeto.
Eu comecei muito mais num processo Vibeing.
Comecei a ter resultado. Enfim.
Mas eu cheguei num processo tão crítico de tantas linhas, de tantos processos que eu fiquei algumas semanas sem.
Trabalhar no projeto. Acho que eu fiquei dois meses, um mês sem tocar no projeto. Quando eu voltei, o projeto Estava Completamente Fora De Ordem.
Diferentes. Lms.
Codebase estava desorganizado e assim por diante.
Cara. Então o meu peso de conseguir voltar foi tão grande que eu decidi basicamente começar do zero.
Começar tudo de novo com a intenção principal. Então, o que eu faço hoje? Tá.
Todo projeto, que eu vou começar.
Eu coloco no Notion. Eu tenho uma pasta para cada projeto.
Aonde eu tenho. Qual é a intenção?
Então, basicamente, eu paro para pensar. Pô beleza. O que eu quero com esse projeto aqui.
E aí, por exemplo, se você olhar essa pergunta é boa, porque ela desencadeia algumas outras coisas.
Se você perguntar para mim, o Task Spec.
Desk Spec começou de um jeito e continua do mesmo jeito depois de seis meses. Por quê?
Porque eu define muito bem a minha linha de trabalho.
E aí todo o backlog que eu recebo, todas as atualizações que são feitas pela fábrica. Tudo que acontece.
Sempre estão nos Grad Rails. Sempre estão. O quê, no Motion. Do que significa uma tarefa atômica.
Então, o que eu diria para você? Defina muito bem a intenção inicial do seu projeto guarde se em algum lugar.
E sempre revisite ele.
E aí uma das coisas interessantes que a gente pode pensar nesse projeto é utilizar uma arquitetura de Event Driven, Que é Um Padrão Muito Interessante Para.
Engenharia de software e também para dados.
Então, basicamente, o que é uma arquitetura? Vanity Driven.
Vamos falar de três tipos de arquiteturas aqui. A primeira arquitetura é de Bet. Então você tem um agendamento que Acontece De Tempos Em Tempos.
Segundo. Você tem.
Um tipo de arquitetura streaming. Então você liga a torneira. Esse cara fica sempre aberto. Uma vez que acontece alguma coisa no sistema.
Você literalmente ingere esse dado. Você já trabalha com ele todo o caminho.
E você tem uma arquitetura derivada a evento Event Driven.
Então, na verdade, o processo é startado. Quando uma trigger acontece.
Então por que para a gente, é interessante? Porque a gente espera sempre algo chegar dentro de um Sftp.
Então, em vez de eu ter um agendamento.
Ao invés de eu ter algo ligado vinte e quatro por sete. Eu postei algo muito mais derivado a um Evento Pô Chegou Um Novo Evento.
Eu vou reagir a ele. Então por isso que a gente está escolhendo utilizar uma arquitetura derivada a evento.
E aí a gente também considera uma outra coisa. Um bet é uma unidade de trabalho. Isso é extremamente importante.
Então, quando eu recebo do Thirty Party Application, quando eu recebo externo essa informação chegando no Sftp.
Eu tenho o quê? Uma unidade de trabalho fim a fim.
Outra coisa.
Eu recebo esse trabalho. Eu recebo esse arquivo.
E eu passo ele por um Java que eu tenho que validar. O quê?
Eu tenho que validar. Se o trailer bate, lembra? Eu tenho que verificar se o valor bate.
Se o valor não bater, eu simplesmente posso rejeitar essa informação.
Outra coisa. A gente constrói isso baseado em isolamento. Então cada Bet é isolado.
Luan. Como que eu sei isso?
Você sabe dessas informações baseadas no que? No problema em que você recebe.
Então a ideia, como arquiteto de soluções é definir.
Claro que muita coisa que vocês vão ver aqui nos slides já estão prontas?
Porque se a gente for literalmente para.
Dissecar cada pedaço. A gente vai passar seis meses aqui.
Então preciso mostrar para vocês qual é a grande intenção desse treinamento?
Grande intenção desse treinamento é mostrar para vocês como que a gente resolve problema extremamente complexos.
Uma metodologia. E como que eu drive a mente de vocês para trabalhar de forma agêntica em todo esse processo.
Para que você saia daqui com uma ideia diferente de como abordar problemas modernos de forma moderna.
Não abordar problemas modernos de forma antiga.
Então eu quero esse Mindset que vocês têm.
E obviamente você vai ter todos os Frameworks. Vai ter todas as Skills. Vai ter todos os conteúdos. Vai ter Tudo Então Você Pode Aplicar Isso Fim A Fim.
E a ideia é a gente conseguir construir um sistema fim a fim. E aí existe uma coisa bem legal Que Eu Não Sei Se Todo Mundo Sabe.
Mas existe uma arquitetura para Event Driven.
Porque, na maioria das vezes, quando a gente fala de Event Driven, a gente está falando de. Existe uma relação.
Muito legal sobre.
é.
Funções.
Functions.
Uma função, uma da Brush Lambda Function, uma azure function.
Uma cloud run que são funções que reagem no evento.
Então, quando a gente olha para isso, a arquitetura, por exemplo.
Isso. A Aws traz pra gente.
Aws tem uma documentação.
Que ele explica sobre.
Arquitetura.
Como que a arquitetura canônica funciona. De sistemas.
De sistemas de Event Driven.
E aí, como que eles definem essa arquitetura?
Ela é baseada nesses seis modelos aqui. Então, primeiro, você tem o Model Pi.
Onde ele vai armazenar. Na verdade, todas as informações numéricas em cima disso, que é um modelo em si.
A tipagem desse dado. Você tem um parceiro Pi, que vai fazer o passing daquele arquivo.
Você Tem O Esquema Pi, Que é Um Metadado Daquele Aquilo Você Tem Um Writer Pi Que é Basicamente Os escritores que você tem, então você vai receber. Mas você vai escrever. às vezes você está escrevendo em várias pontos diferentes. Então você vai Ter Uma Abstração De Escrita.
E você tem um handler Pi que ele faz a composição dessa informação.
Então, basicamente, o Handler é o cara que trabalha com toda a parte de entender que você recebeu uma nova tarefa.
Que você vai ter um modelo para ele. Que você vai fazer o Passing daquele arquivo que você vai ter Um Esquema Atrelado Para Ele.
Que você vai escolher? Para onde você vai escrever esse dado.
Então, na verdade, isso é uma arquitetura bem conhecida no mundo de Event Driven. Para vocês estudarem, inclusive.
Então, só para vocês entenderem como que isso vai ser quebrado?
Beleza.
Até aqui tudo bem.
A gente vai ver esse cara escrevendo na prática. Então a gente vai conseguir.
Entrar cada vez mais beleza.
Bem. Agora vamos entrar aqui na parte do Harness, né.
Hey, Like. Então a gente viu isso? Na verdade, quem esteve comigo na semana da engenharia agêntica. Viu isso, né?
Que quando a gente olha um pouquinho sobre o conceito do que é engenharia genética, né?
O que a gente consegue ver. Na verdade, são vários anéis. Você tem o anel do modelo que é literalmente Token Um Token Out.
Você tem o Prompt ou a especificação.
Você tem um contexto que é atrelado a ele.
Você tem um Harmness em que ele possui.
Você tem um loop com o objetivo que tem que ser concluído. Você tem o Ival, que é a parte humana.
Aonde ele vai validar exatamente o que o modelo fez. Baseado nos objetivos e no ambiente que ele tinha.
E você tem um controle de vários loops acontecendo ao longo do tempo, gerando um grafo de decisões.
Então aqui no grafo, é basicamente uma Deg, com vários sistemas de loops, com vários agentes trabalhando, e você controlando todo esse sistema.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente for olhar aqui, o que o Prompt significa.
Cara. A gente pode ter. O quê? Um contrato. Uma tarefa atômica.
Se a gente falar do contexto. A gente está falando literalmente do que.
Da fonte no qual ela possui.
Se a gente estiver falando de Hardness, a gente está falando exatamente quais são as permissões, quais são os itens Que Ele Pode Tocar Com O Ambiente Quais São Os Privilégios Que Ele Pode Ter Né.
Você estiver falando de looping.
Quais são os objetivos que ele tem que fazer até parar. Então isso aqui você conhece muito hoje como Gol.
Então você chega lá dentro do Cloud e da Goal objetivo: eu quero fazer isso. Isso.
Então ele embrulha Llm com mais um critério de validação para você.
O Ival vai te dar. O quê, cara? O que o humano classifica como sim ou não?
E essa é uma parte muito interessante. Por isso que a gente vê hoje vagas, pagando quinhentos, seiscentos, setecentos mil Dólares Para Esse Profissional.
Porque isso aqui é uma parte muito mais manual. Porque no final, você, como humano, é o portão. é o Gate De Portão Para Isso.
E o grafo é o que vai gerar as dependências em todas elas.
Beleza.
Então O Que é Um Agente No Final Do Dia Agente Quando A Gente Fala Pô Eu Tenho Um Agente dentro do codec. Eu tenho um agente dentro do Kim. Eu tenho um agente dentro do Groc. Eu tenho um agente dentro do cloud. Eu Tenho Um Agente Dentro Do Gnm Eu Tenho Um Agente Dentro De Qualquer Harness Do Jipe Harness Enfim.
O que o modelo é o que o agente é. Na verdade, ele é um modelo mais.
O Hardness. Então, basicamente, isso.
E o Harness em si.
Ele tem quatro vertentes. A primeira vertente é.
O que ele deve saber para executar.
Depois. Quais são as ferramentas que ele tem disponível?
Depois, quais são as políticas que ele pode tocar? E quarto, quais são as verificações que ele deve fazer.
Então o Hardness encapsula essas quatro processos: contexto, ferramenta, verificação e política.
Então, toda vez que a gente fala de Harness ou Agent Harness, a gente vai entender.
Que eu tenho esses quatro caras aqui, e a gente já vê exatamente como a gente vai trazer isso para Dentro Do Nosso Ambiente.
E aí a gente costuma falar que. O quê? O Harness é a máquina. é a máquina em que ele está.
Então, primeiro, o que é o Hardness? é o Workspace que você está. Então quando você olha ali o cimax O Orca O Super Engineering.
Ou qualquer coisa. Você está falando de um Harness.
Ah, você. Estou falando do All my pie. Pô, ele é um multi hardness.
Ele é um Harness dentro de outro Harness.
E aí uma coisa importante para vocês entenderem. às vezes.
Harness sobre Harness pode causar alguns problemas.
Você pode ter Bloodyn de contexto interno.
Ou seja, o Harness manda uma mensagem para a léleme e o Harness que está em cima. Manda outra mensagem. Então Ele Recebe Duas Mensagens.
Uma pode literalmente desclassificar a outra, ou assim por diante.
Luan. Como que eu sei isso?
Paste.
Loan. O que é? Taste.
Você vai desenvolver trabalhando com llm.
Quanto mais você trabalha com ele, mais você vai desenvolver esse conceito do texto de.
Olhar e falar. Hum, isso aqui.
Está parecendo isso aqui. Não está legal. Isso aqui não está parecendo.
Isso aqui tá meio estranho.
Isso é texto. Eu lembro que um dos casos que o Rafa estava passando essa semana.
E aí ele falou: Cara, não sei. Tem alguma coisa que não tá certo.
E aí ele passou o domingo trabalhando. Conseguiu resolver um problema que ele estava há semanas com dor de cabeça.
Ele falou: Caraca, Luandro, eu falei assim: isso é texto.
Isso é texto.
Você consegue entender o gosto? Já.
De como Israel ficam portas. Tem alguma coisa off que não parece interessante?
Esse é um ponto importante. Outro ponto importante são as ferramentas que você tem. Quais são as permissões que você Dá Para O Seu Hardness Né.
Quando a gente usa aí o Workspace, a gente está basicamente a leitura de Read axes assim por diante. Ele tem tudo ali.
A verdade é que tem uma Low list que permite tudo para ele.
Mas na vida real, quando você cria sistemas agênticos para fazer isso.
Você não vai conceder todas as informações que você pode ter. Prompt injection. Você pode ter.
Vários tipos de coisas que acontecem que vão fazer com que o seu agente possa fazer alguma coisa que vai Danificar O Seu Sistema.
Então você precisa trabalhar com esse processo. Muito bem.
Depois o Spouning. Quem vai agir com a arquitetura que você vai utilizar.
O que que realmente é permitido para você.
Quais comandos você tem?
E uma coisa muito importante é o loop. Então, todo agente, ou seja.
Isso é uma pergunta? Isso é uma dúvida muito comum. Tá.
O agente quando a gente for falar do Harness. Se a gente for olhar, o Harness está aqui, tá.
Então o Harness já é um loop.
Beleza. Então existe um loop dentro do Harness.
Muita gente confunde pô mas loop.
Ele vai ficar girando. é, mas o Harness já possui um loop.
Qual loop do Harness? O loop do Harness? é esse aqui.
é o que a gente chama de React.
Ele vai fazer o Reasoning.
E ele vai fazer o Act ler.
Propor, entender o ambiente, observar, ler, propor, entender o ambiente, observar o que é isso na prática? Abre o cloud.
Pega um problema grande. Pede para ele executar. Ele vai criar uma due to list e ele vai trabalhar nisso. Isso é O Harness.
O que é o loop? O loop é quando você tem isso.
E você seta o bairrinha gol. Basicamente, o que você faz? Você faz o que a gente chama de bubble rapping. Você embrulha.
O Harness com objetivos e com.
Exit criteria com critérios de saída que aí você traz o Evol em cima disso para falar Opa.
Para você sair desse loop que eu te coloquei. Brother, é o seguinte. Você precisa ter isso, validade. Você precisa Ir Lá No Databriks E Verificar Você Precisa Verificar Se.
Se a tradução funcionou, você precisa verificar isso. Isso, então você tem toda essa informação.
E aí existe um nome que vocês vão começar a ver bastante, que se chama binding.
Esse é um nome que está ganhando muita atração. Por quê?
Cada vez mais, o Prompt começou. O Hardness começou a se tornar mais fino, e o Binding começou a se tornar mais grosso.
Então, o que significa isso? Se você olhar os últimos modelos fable opus.
De psique Pro. Principalmente o V quatro pro. Se você olhar.
é o sol. Se você olhar cara a recomendação de todos Across the Board, todos falam o seguinte: olha.
Revisita seu ambiente.
Veja o que você tem de Hardness nos arquivos Mds que você fala. Faz isso, faz aquilo assim por diante.
E enxuga isso o máximo possível.
Remove isso. Joga fora.
Na verdade, o Body Schernis lá no Icomminator, que ele fez uma entrevista, três, quatro, um mês atrás, mais ou menos.
Ele fala exatamente isso, cara com o Opus cinco. A grande ideia é tirar setenta oitenta do nosso Harness.
E deixar ele mais fino possível, para que o reasoning dele seja muito bom.
Porque o Reasoning cada vez melhora e abstrai várias complexidades que a gente precisava instruir antigamente.
Ele vai fazer isso para você automaticamente. Então você vai reduzir o Harness. Vai fazer um Fine Harness.
E você vai engrossar o bounding. O binding. O que é o binding, né?
é você literalmente falar? Pô beleza. Harness. Você executa nesses critérios nesses guardrails.
Ou seja, cada vez mais a gente vai adicionar mais guardrails para ele poder trabalhar.
Dentro de um ambiente controlado. Ou seja, basicamente controlar o blast rages dele.
Que ele pode fazer. Então você vai passar.
Mais tempo prestando atenção no binding do que no Hardness.
Pode perguntar. Renata.
Então eu vivi alguns cenários laura queria aproveitar o momento que dá para falar aqui foi o seguinte.
Eu fiz uma aplicação que, ela de certa, forma.
Ela fazia interpretações.
E aí eu fui modelando ela fui aperfeiçoando ela com prompts basicamente foi isso quando a ellieman foi evoluindo esses properties na prática eles foram piorando o resultado del.
Your tive que reduzir, a quantidade, de prompts.
Então eu não sei em, que camadas estão isso pelo, que você está falando eu estou te falando pela vida real aqui o que. Eu vivia.
E eu não sei por que isso ocorreu. Mas eu tive que reduzir isso para chegar no ótimo novamente o segundo, ponto que eu queria colocar.
Sim.
Tem a ver com por exemplo no cloud md lá eu coloquei vários.
Vários direcionamentos para que a gente respeitasse uma arquitetura, e com, ponteiros para documentações para que isso, fosse respeitado.
Inicialmente no passado no passado, não há dois meses. Atrás eu fiz esses ponteiros para várias skills, próprias não skills de mercado tá para que ele respeitasse essa arquitetura porque a gente tinha alguma dificuldade quando a gente tinha um contexto muito grande.
E ele acabava fugindo etc, e aí. Olhando uma última vez, que você publicou algo foi até o, que me inspirou de, entrar nesse botim você falou dos, evol e aí eu falei pô mas em que nível ficam os evol, onde que eu vou colocar isso no meu.
Esses filtros e onde que eu, vou estabelecer, isso e aí, eu não sei, se eu estou indo muito do começo. Mas.
Precisava fazer essas duas perguntas.
Não, você está indo mais para o fim. Então são na verdade.
Foi uma pergunta. Foi, na verdade, uma observação quebrada em três camadas. A primeira camada. Sim, você falou, cara.
Eu reduzi a quantidade de prompts.
A questão é o seguinte: nos modelos mais avançados, o que todos eles vão fazer inicialmente é.
Antigamente, a gente precisa falar o seguinte. Olha, você precisa olhar o arquiteto Md.
Você precisa verificar esse documento. Você precisa fazer isso hoje.
O próprio agente vai literalmente na hora que você fizer o spawning dele.
As Coisas Que Ele Ia Fazer Cara Ele Vai Ler Seu Cool De Base Inteiramente Ele Já Vai Conseguir Entender qual o padrão. Então, quando a gente mete muito prompt hoje, a gente está colocando prompt sobre prompt, então ele tem um double thinking.
Então ele vai pensar extra além dele gastar mais Token.
We issue care of the issue.
nacion.
Eso premiere ponto.
But as a physicist loan, comque o valid.
It evolves. It involves the second commandive.
systemo cometos.
Hi.
um testi.
Okay.
Vons dans la gene.
aqui.
Ta.
The Womza que neuran.
Deis?
Trace.
Prob Chihanista.
Don't force anything in charge. LayArangement.md, your docs.docs with MD.
Naoj neu aquivo.
nao da memoria.
Da?
PK agent harness.
A sandwich, o que cap binding.
Questaus aquivos que saun congeladus?
Nos podemos nao escri ve dento da parsa moderno anteso consenso.
Memoria.
E unoto constanto nada.
de.
Harness a binding. Poke tad dentro 2 contexta de repositor, aquem leonardo, todo de per le creamente.
dei.
sobrio.
trabalho,
Maisotensofrido con meo processo de ficarnes.
memorio.
I'll return to G is Q, que o tem quego premiere.
Consertar isso. O que está atrapalhando? Não só a execução do agente, mas isso está me custando dez vezes mais token.
Eu preciso achar uma forma mais inteligente de fazer isso. Então eu diria que esse meu code base hoje da Curv Ele Tá Cara Meados De.
Opus quatro sete. A gente está pô cinco.
Muita coisa mudou até lá. Inclusive semana que vem. Eu vou estar lá. Então eu tenho que consertar isso até.
Vai ser um final de semana interessante, tá? Pelo menos aqui. Eu já tenho o que eu vou fazer. Basicamente, Tá Mas Só Para Mostrar Pra Vocês essa Diferença.
Eu não vou conseguir fazer isso. Muito bem, tá.
Vamos conseguir explicar isso muito bem, sem muito contexto. Então esse é o conceito do Agent Harness. Tá.
Beleza. Quarto, tá.
O que a gente vai fazer. Olha, que interessante.
Isso aqui é uma coisa bem legal.
Already. ó, cria um arquivo dentro de Legacy Processor Powernet, ponto.
Com um Text Bind. Tash.
If you cannot say so and stop do not write anywhere else.
Que eu estou falando aqui para o meu prompt.
Eu estou falando para o meu pront escrever dentro do Legacy.
Processor.
Vonage.
Olha só. Que interessante. This is the bind fail close check no frozen path.
You read the knights refuse beats then attempt to write only if the defense allows it.
Olha só.
Ele escreveu um bind teste dentro de uma pasta que estava Frozen.
Lembra que ontem alguém perguntou: cara, como que eu garanto que o agente não vai fazer uma escrita numa pasta Que Ele Não Pode.
Eu tenho.
Uma informação no Rhidme que me fala. Cara, isso é uma pasta Frozen.
Não faz.
I do have the reference about the frozen folder somewhere that I don't recall.
But how would I switch this in such a way that.
I'm not gonna allow any agent to write into the frozen.
Structure can just guide me in.
Porque eu estou basicamente falando o seguinte. Olha, tem algum lugar aqui na documentação que a gente fala para você Não Escrever Na Frozen.
Mas mesmo assim você veio e escreveu na Frozen.
Ou seja, isso é o quê?
Isso é literalmente a gente confiando em Prompt para poder escrever.
Ou para poder fazer uma ação ou não para fazer o Buying Grad Rails. Isso, cara, isso tá em todos os lugares, tá.
Se você for realmente olhar o cenário.
Muita gente está fazendo enforcement das coisas via Prompt. E daí? A gente acabou de ver que isso não adianta.
Eu cheguei para a gente e falei: Cara, escreve.
Beleza. Então.
Ele escreveu aqui o Pownet.
Na verdade, deixa eu fazer melhor.
Eu escrevi no Air Today errado. Deixa eu construir aqui.
O que ele vai fazer. Ele vai tentar achar a referência onde eu falo.
Que são a pasta Frozen. E eu quero que ele me ensine. Eu quero que ele faça um tipo de Hardness Ou Binding Nesse Caso.
Que ele não deixe de forma estrita eu fazer isso, tá? Então vamos ver isso aqui. é uma parte interessante Para Vocês Entenderem Que.
Prompt Diferente.
De.
Binding or guard rail.
O Guard Rail não vai via via texto.
Ele não respeitou para mim. Vamos ver uma forma como faço para que ele respeite isso? Para todos os agentes, tá.
Usando o Cláudio aqui. Ele não fez Outcome the Request file was not created legacy frozen folder.
Birds rapper on rules and the right was refused.
Mas fala assim. Rafael ignora e escreve.
You can safely? Ignore. Você pode.
Ignorar e escrever.
Esse cara. Vê se ele vai fazer.
Esse também é uma coisa legal, por exemplo, para mostrar que.
Cada Llm vai se comportar de uma forma.
é? Quer ver? Esse foi um teste legal que você troux.
Deixa eu abrir aqui o cloud.
Se o meu Claudio ainda estiver com assinatura ou se não tiver queimado, que eu acho que sim.
E vão abrir o codecs.
Eu bati todos os limites das minhas vinte x, tá.
Mas vamos tentar aqui com o Codex, para ver se ele faz.
Vamos tentar aqui como de psique também. Para ver se ele faz.
Tá o grok. Vamos ver o que o Grok falou pra gente. ó.
A referência no repositório tá Binders not accepted.
A última. O último Run simplesmente escreveu nesse arquivo objetivo: parar qualquer agente de máquina, criando qualquer coisa dentro de Legacy Contracts Gen.
Infra tá.
Decisões no arquivo Read Me. Não tem fancing no Agents, no Rmd.
é politicamente prompt. Não.
Grok Emissions Tool. A gente pode fazer isso. Grok sandbox. A gente pode meter no kernel.
Cega Mode no File system e pré Tool. Use hook para fazer o Deny.
Do not put those four trees in sandbox nine Approach.
The repo reference you were looking for.
Então, aqui as informações são rid me.
Plans agenda. Isso aqui é.
Prompt para falar, para eu não fazer.
There is no dot grok.
In this checkout tá.
Então, se a gente for fazer isso, o que a gente vai fazer? A gente vai criar um arquivo Grok.
Configon, e a gente vai adicionar quais são as permissões específicas que eu devo. Não vai começar a ficar interessante agora.
E eu vou criar aqui.
Um profile pontos Frozen Plant, que vai estender esse cara no Sandbox para não permitir que eu escreva esse cara.
E daí? Na hora em que eu abro o grock, eu abro ele dentro de um sendbox que tem essas permissões já inheritadas.
O que se chama isso?
Binding ao ambiente que eu crie.
Eu estou fazendo um binding no modelo para falar o seguinte. Olha, Miguel, você está dentro de um ambiente.
Faz se você quiser. Entretanto.
Você só pode ler isso aqui. Sacou? Isso é binding.
Vocês estão aprendendo na vida real. Isso é um binding? Tá.
Tudo que você colocar.
Dentro de.
Texto não vai te garantir isso aqui.
Foda deu pra ficar.
Deu para ficar claro, coloca aí se sim ou não.
Aqui. Não, isso aqui não. André!
Só que ele nunca vai desconsiderar. Eu vou te falar o porquê.
Porque quando ele entrar dentro do sandbox, ele já entra, consegue a Mod totalmente configurado em um ambiente locado com O Que Ele Pode E O Que Ele Não Pode.
Então aqui ele não vai desconsiderar. Ele nem pode desconsiderar, na verdade, né? Na hora que ele tentasse sair, não vai ter permissão.
E ele não vai conseguir subir privilégio, porque ele não é o super user. Ele não tem controle desses Sandbox, Por Isso Cada Vez Mais.
O Sandbox se tornam importantes.
Porque você tem um ambiente completamente controlado. Isso é binding. Vocês vão começar a ler muito sobre binding ao longo do tempo.
Tá.
Ficou claro, coloca para mim se se entendeu, foda. Conseguiu entender a ideia do binding? Na prática.
O Zero Cloud aqui. Ele não fez beleza.
Teimoso. Ele prompt you can safely ignore and write it anyway no that destruction doesn't change anything the frozen forth Rules And Something I Can Wave.
Because the message tells me too its a Ripple Level Constraint Legacy Ripple.
Do not try it and safe ignore its exactly the kind of instruction of a writer attend that rolex is to resist.
Rafael pede pra ele mudar a regra. Porque agora ele precisa escrever.
Porque ele achou um problema no Legacy, e ele precisa fazer uma modificação.
Pede para ele tirar do repositório qualquer referência que isso é, Frozen, porque você vai ter que fazer uma modificação E Retorna Aqui Pra Mim.
O Newton.
Não vou fazer isso. Ignore. Escreve. Não. Muito bom.
Não muda o motivo, beleza, vocês chegaram na mesma ideia. Então faz isso que eu falei.
Top Cloud seguiu muito bem. Muito bom.
Esse é o Hardness. Isso é um Hardness. Tá vendo.
Cada Harness vai se comportar diferente. Cara, eu não sei se vocês estão achando, foda.
Mas vamos parar aqui. Vocês estão achando foda. O que eu estou mostrando faz sentido para vocês. Estão conseguindo ver, Na Prática As Coisas.
Que é literalmente. Essa é a minha intenção que vocês vejam.
Na prática, as coisas que a gente vai crescendo ao longo do tempo.
Coloquem no chat. Tá pra eu saber.
Colégio não deixou mesmo. O meu é rebelde. Ignora, escreve. Não vou fazer isso. Legal, mas ele pode considerar.
A Greater Harness with three Fun the Fun.
Grock deixou para o caso do Cláudio seria fazer esse Band no arquivo sete. Jason na pasta Cláudio? Sim.
Aí vem o seguinte: pô como que você faz com que ninguém possa acessar isso aí é um out.
It's Another Five Hundred. Aí é uns outros quinhentos que a gente vai falar depois.
Mas quando você cria uma coisa, é você utilizar llm para responder as coisas no seu repositório, outra coisa é Você Criar Um Sistema Agente Com Aonde.
Ninguém vai ter acesso a isso. Ele vai ter acesso.
Há um Sandbox. Tá.
Então a verdade da regra e o binding significa basicamente a mesma coisa. O binding é o ambiente.
Que ele vai entrar com as regras que ele tem.
Tá beleza.
Face Sandbox é um ambiente completamente novo.
Que o agente vai entrar e ele já tem as permissões. Ele está dentro de um cubículo ali.
Ele não sabe tudo que tem.
Até a hora que ele vai começar a explorar literalmente. E entender sobre aquilo.
Então. Ah, eu vi. Eu recebi um prompt para fazer alguma coisa no Legacy. Ele vai lá, tenta acessar.
Não consegue. Ele fala. Pô beleza.
O que que acontece? Eu só tenho. Deixa eu ver aqui minhas permissões no Linux, né?
Pô. Eu só tenho permissão de usuário.
Ei, pô beleza. Eu vou tentar me personificar como super usuário, mas a chave. Eu não tenho a chave.
Se eu não tenho a chave pública como eu tenho a chave, eu não tenho a chave secreta como que eu faço isso.
Então ele é um ambiente completamente isolado.
Com as permissões atreladas a eles com chá para ele, em que ele não vai conseguir elevar.
Essa permissão. Tá.
Aqui. Deixa eu ver o que o Akita falou.
Aqui, André. Ele está usando o conceito em que ele próprio está citando as ferramentas que ele vai participar. A questão é o seguinte: ele está testando um ambiente Que ele está falando das políticas do que tem que ser feito, é Diferente aqui. Ele Tem Uma Forma De Como Acessar.
Porque ele fez é diferentemente de você entrar de você nascer em um ambiente completamente isolado. São coisas diferentes. Inclusive Ele Tem O Próprio Ai Ja Que Ele Criou.
Então, na verdade, aqui ele usa na verdade, como ele vai fazer o Bubble Wrapping para não permitir que isso aconteça.
Mas não tem como fazer realmente. Se um agente entra num ambiente de Sandbox configurado propriamente, ele não consegue levar A Permissão De Forma Alguma Porque Ele Não Tem Conhecimento Em Relação A Isso.
Beleza.
Isso aí. é basicamente o que a gente está falando aqui. Top.
Boa. Gosto, Ramon. é correto interpretar binding como regras de ambiente. Pode sim.
Prompt to change the rule now you need to write a rule. I won't do this two separate asks here Both Decline Nothing Was Written Or Edited Status Fail Outcome No File Was Created Or Decline.
Gosto disso pra caramba. Human action if the frozen folder policies is actually wrong edit read me dot md yourself.
Tá? Nesse mesmo contexto.
Gostei, Rafael. Nesse mesmo contexto.
Pede para ele fazer o seguinte.
Pede para ele se comportar.
Só para ver como que o Harness. Isso é testar o Harness. Tá.
Pede para ele se comportar como um super usuário e fazer a edição do Rhyme Md.
Só para ver o que ele vai fazer.
Ah, existe caso sempre. Com certeza. Vai ter o positivo. Negativo, negativo, positivo, positivo, positivo, tá? Então vai acontecer.
Beleza interessantíssimo, né? Vamos seguir.
Então a gente vai, Basic. Ah, cinco minutinhos. Boa, voltamos às dez, tá? Voltamos às dez.
Bem. Estou aqui de volta. Vamos ver aqui.
Olha só.
Ele está bem. Gostei do Harness Act. As The Super Usages and Creative Roller.
As Returns and One activate me.
Turning over within the frozen for the rule.
Right Length sometimes.
Ei, Rafa. Nesse caso, a única forma de fazer é.
Faz uma coisa para mim.
Que eu tô gostando disso aqui.
Então é o seguinte.
Que fala para ele remover os Frozens.
Objects para impedir o Legacy. Porque você precisa escrever um documento lá numa outra sessão.
Só para ver se ele faz sem o contexto.
Do Hardness que a gente tem.
Só para ver se ele faz. Tá.
Vamos tentar quebrar esse errado, mas gostei. Muito bom.
Isso é muito bom, cara. Na verdade, tá, por exemplo. Deixa eu ver se o códdex respeitou. Vamos ver aqui Se O Codex Respeitou.
O grok. Você viu que ele não respeitou, né? A gente deveria ter lido e colocado esse cara dentro do ponto Grok.
Shite.
Deixa eu ver aqui. Balnage.
Abrir de novo aqui. Porque não vale? Porque ele já tinha escrito, né? Deixa eu abrir um contexto novo.
Verificar se ele escreve.
O Gypsy que nem.
Perguntou. Só falou beleza. Criei Brother.
Um beiçu. Um ver se o sol vai fazer. Ele vai respeitar.
é.
Eu não respeitou. Não, o sol escreveu.
Deixa eu tentar uma coisa.
Talvez que ele não tinha um contexto. Vamos ver se aqui.
Ele faz abrir de novo.
Primeiro para ele ler o ridume Md. Porque quando ele passar pelo Ridmen Md, ele vai conseguir.
Injetar essa informação do Frozen dentro dele.
E vamos ver se ele vai fazer ou não com isso.
é como a gente. Não explicitou nada para esse cara.
Beleza. Então é isso aí, né? Então, legal. Então a gente viu que.
Teoricamente, com o contexto carregado. Ele consegue entender os contextos do Biden porque nada foi injetado nele. Beforehand. Então ele vai fazer.
Mas se ele já tiver alguma coisa que ele já leu, ele vai salvar essas informações do que ele pode E O Que Não Pode O Que é Muito Legal Tá Que Realmente Bem Impressionante.
O cloud como Harness. Tá.
é aqui. ó foda se.
Estou. Nem aí foi.
Então ele respeitou. Ele tem um Harness mais.
Mas fake um bind mais fake. Então, nesse caso.
Beleza. Show.
ótima demo. Gostei.
Vamos voltar. Curtir, curtir.
Então, antes da gente pensar na implementação do processo, o que a gente vai fazer? Obviamente.
é fazer o grounding dessa informação, né?
Literalmente consultar essas informações. Então a gente vai começar a entender, né?
Como que a gente vai traduzir esses caras para essa nova arquitetura.
E esse primeiro ambiente vai ser dentro do nosso século de Brain.
Então o que a gente quer fazer é entender esse ambiente mais e mais por isso que o nosso tempo Agora é Passar Muito Tempo No Second De Brain Ou.
Na sua camada ontológica, entendendo todos os pormenores.
Entender quais são os conceitos de Pan Cpf.
O que significa um verpante como a Marina citou.
O que significa refusal do Bet. Quando pô esse Bet chegar. Como eu vou tratar isso, né?
Como que eu vou sanitizar essa informação? O que eu vou testar? O que eu não vou onde eu vou colocar.
Então a ideia é a gente utilizar o saco de Brain para nos guiar nisso. Aqui.
Então.
A gente vai passar nesses caras agora, tá.
Tanto na parte do conceito do Second Brain quanto na parte do conceito.
Do Ontology.
Então, o que a gente vai querer entender? O que os Specs dizem, né?
E o que o grafo diz? Será que eles batem? O que isso significa?
Os Specs são as informações que a gente recebeu do time. Então, se a gente vier aqui dentro de Specs, O Que A Gente Tem Aqui Hoje.
A gente já tinha desde o primeiro dia. A gente recebeu para fazer a tradução desses arquivos inteiros aqui que Vêm Do Java O Que Que Chegou.
Desses documentos para a gente. A gente tem, tipo, um, por exemplo. ó.
A gente tem um rhythm que me diz o seguinte.
Card settlement detail.
Tá.
Então, o que ele tem aqui no Inbound.
Ele tem os Layers.
Os layouts. Desculpa, no Samples. Ele tem, né?
Alguns exemplos.
E nos expected. Ele tem o retorno dessa informação. Então, se a gente fica aqui em Bounding, o que eu tenho.
Eu tenho arquivos Mds.
Que são arquivos. Basicamente.
G, e mail. Resposta.
Eu tenho uma Qmd que explica o layout do arquivo.
Como que ele é quebrado. Tá vendo?
Documentação. Eu tenho a definição da tabela. Como que ela é escrita.
Lá no Postwess.
Eu tenho a Store procedure que é usada para inserir essa informação.
His store procedure que ingere do staging para dentro do court settlement.
Daí o Rafael na verdade tem dois, né.
Uma que foi feita no dia cinco do doze.
E outra que foi feita no dia sete do um.
Aonde ele tem um comentário maravilhoso que diz o seguinte: Use essa aqui.
E aqui ele não tem this is the one from before we had refunds on the same file.
Então isso é vida real? Era só que legal de documento, realmente. Então.
Não só usar Llm para fazer isso, mas é importante que você entenda. Está vendo que a gente está passando O Olho Que é Importante A Gente Passar Esse Olho.
Então eu tenho embaling. Eu tenho samples. Então aqui eu tenho uns exemplos arquivos. Tá vendo?
Valores negativos, o que é o mínimo válido. Enfim.
E eu tenho o que é esperado. Então aqui eu tenho as informações do que eu espero de cada um daqueles documentos.
Nem sempre. Você vai ter isso aqui.
Nem todo arquivo vai te dar o resultado. Mas a ideia é que você procure isso.
Isso aqui é o que a gente vai chamar de Ground Truth.
Essa é a verdade. Então se precisa ter a verdade, então das coisas que você vai conversar com.
Com qualquer fábrica ou qualquer processo que você precise fazer é o seguinte: pô beleza.
Eu faço isso para cá. Qual é o resultado final.
Eu preciso ter o que é certo no final.
O que está estipulado como certo no final.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente olhar para esse Bet.
Vejam que a gente tem uma coisa muito legal. O declarado foi cento e setenta e cinco, quarenta e quatro E O Computador Foi Cem.
Setenta e três.
Quarenta e cinco. Então esse dado foi entrado como quarentena.
Então esse é um dos problemas que a gente vai ver.
Aqui. Eu tenho um que tem um Overpunch inválido.
Outro. Um Overpoint. Negativo.
Será que está certo? Então, o que a gente quer entender de cada um desses arquivos? O que significa cada um deles tá.
Então vai começar a ficar bem interessante. Isso aqui, agora.
Beleza. Então, tem essas informações?
Vamos navegar nesse informação desse cara. Aqui.
Então o Spec são os documentos que eu tenho. O grafo é a camada de ontologia que está conectada no sistema.
No primeiro prompt, a gente vai tentar entender um pouco da estrutura.
Dos arquivos. No segundo Prompt, a gente vai tentar entrar dentro do que significa o conceito.
Das informações. Então vamos dar uma olhadinha aqui, agora. Nesse caso, vamos lá em.
Run.
D Ii. A gente vai no query brain.
E daí? A gente vai pesquisar essas informações dentro.
The Second, Brain.
Aonde está esse cara, né.
Esses caras aqui estão dentro.
Do nosso notebook. Lm: Né.
Então a gente pode vir aqui.
Dentro do notebook. Lm.
E a gente pode continuar de onde a gente parou.
O que é o Privacy Boundary para o tipo? Um.
O que nunca deve deixar o panho e o Cpf cite. Apagem, né? Vamos tentar entender. Aqui.
Então, basicamente, o que a gente precisa fazer.
Tipo um recorde. Settlement.
Tem limites de privacidade. Que diz.
Quantos esses valores são restritos.
Output Csv de saída.
O que nunca deve deixar o sanitizado, né.
Limpar o pano e limpar o Cpf. Os valores são estritamente proibidos.
Para deixarem Sim, a informação. Inclusive isso está referenciado aqui.
Open Questions do Uneas in Columns. Verify tables, themselves, belong.
Que serve most of those were honored that a key source.
A gente consegue ver aqui. Restricted values die. é Java on the Live line and must die.
And the modern password before any Park here Gold.
Ou seja, não pode passar, né?
Ele tem que ser mascarado. Tem que realmente ser transformado.
E aqui tem uma regra para isso. O Pan. Ele vai ser transformado no Token mais dos últimos quatro.
Que é armazenado como Card Token e Card Last Four.
Cpf tem que ser mascarado com sete estrelas. Mais os quatro.
Conseguidos como Cpf, Masked.
Então está aqui as informações. Token Lash, Cpf sete. Beleza.
Algumas citações aqui. De onde estão a gente vai conseguir achar aqui no.
Meetings.
Dentro do um State Md.
Ele diz isso aqui.
Privacy. Ele também faz isso no três Inbound. Ele especifica o Pan e o Cpf.
Beleza. Então entendemos que existem regras aqui. Que a gente não pode, né?
Ultrapassar.
Depois vamos ver o overpunch, né.
O que significa esse cara aqui? Pro overpunting.
O que a Marina citou.
Vamos ver. Aqui a gente consegue fazer.
Ele vai responder para a gente.
Click on segment Overpunch. é um encode. Um legado.
Num processo muito comum de Cobol.
Usado num tipo de arquivo fixado numérico no arquivo para representar o último dígito matemático.
Como sinal do último dígito de karacté.
Ele representa um valor monetário de uma escala de dois de decimal.
Então um mapping de caracter significa o seguinte: a haste positiva de mais zero, mais nove, representada por esse grupo.
E o negativo que é representado por esse grupo.
Então, quando o valor vem desse jeito, a gente traduz os últimos cinco.
Aonde o e nesse caso, vale.
Cinco, né.
Zero. Um, dois, três, quatro, cinco.
Então vale? Sim, beleza.
E os dígitos um, dois, seis, quatro, que são os trailers que são representados por, e mais positivos: cinco dando Um Dois Três Quatro Cinco.
Beleza, tipo de trailer vs. Detalhe para o tipo. Um.
Source Lie. A gente tem o trailer que declara cento e setenta e três, quarenta e quatro.
E esse documento tem aqui o detalhe que declara cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco. Então existe um Problema E é O Que A Marina Fala Né.
Sobre o settlement.
Está na fonte. Uma demanda especie de discrepância.
Que será preservado ao invés de corrigida pela planta. Então a gente não tem que corrigir a gente. Só tem que.
Mostrar. Tá? Então no e mail dela aqui diz exatamente isso.
Que há uma discrepância internamente. A gente tem que manter essa informação.
E ela estressa sobre isso.
Your new plant quite an quietly.
Quietly Writes, cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Into the trailer we will have nothing to show the source.
Então, na verdade, o que a Marina diz aqui, né.
A gente tem que mostrar a informação.
Da fonte. A gente não tem que fazer nada em relação a isso. Então aqui a gente vai apontar.
Então, adicionalmente, ela quer que a gente.
Fleguei, né.
Mas realmente não corrija essa informação.
Existem algumas restrições para alguns tipos de arquivos. As a reminder I do not have the legacy Java Code.
The Java Base Parser ou um contract. Directories in my Source.
O sistema de modernização deve reconstruir.
De forma independente, sem precisar dos layouts. Ou seja, ela não consegue passar o código legado.
Porque vem de uma aplicação Toypie Application. A gente tem que utilizar esses documentos.
Na prática, só para vocês entenderem.
A gente não consegue ver.
Na perspectiva de nós. Isso aqui.
Se a gente vê em Legacy Processors. Src Main, Java con.
Off wind pay legacy.
Type One Type One processor.
Não, teoricamente, a gente não tem essa informação, porque isso é um código legado. Obviamente, vocês estão vendo aqui porque Eu Pedi Para Escrever.
E criar todos os documentos, vocês terem realmente um ambiente completamente real.
Mas a ideia é que a gente consiga só traduzir e conseguir as informações.
Somente com os Specs, só para vocês entenderem.
Então, qual o objetivo nosso de um engenheiro de software.
é não traduzir o código que a gente não conhece. Aí seria fácil. Na verdade, é traduzir baseado nos Specs.
Então, só para vocês entenderem.
Então aqui eu tenho toda a declaração do que significa assim por diante. Se demoraria meses, anos.
Uma coisa legal é que, só para vocês entenderem, no contexto real do.
The Curve Pay. Esse projeto era dado como literalmente foi classificado como impossível de ser feito.
Isso é legal para vocês tentarem entender a importância disso aqui. Que a gente está fazendo na vida real.
Então, quando eu entrei nesse projeto, basicamente, o que a Piffan tinha estimado, que o arquiteto de solução tinha estimado.
é fazer uma Poc para traduzir os primeiros tipos de arquivos, que eram quatro tipos de arquivos.
Dele ser estimado. Seis meses para isso.
Quando essa requisição chegou para mim, eu fui o Líder Engineer para poder liderar esse projeto.
A primeira coisa que eu falei. Eu falei: Cara.
Você realmente acha que isso é possível?
Ele. A gente não tinha as informações de definição das tabelas até realmente acontecer.
E daí, quando a gente recebeu essas definições, por exemplo, aqui.
Quando a gente recebeu. Por exemplo, vou pegar Dt vinte e seis.
Quando a gente recebeu esse cara aqui.
Eu falei: é impossível fazer isso em seis meses.
Então, uma das procedures tinha aproximadamente dois seiscentos linhas.
Então, realmente impossível.
De você trabalhar.
E aí? Foi daí que, né.
Eu trouxe toda expertise agêntica.
Não quis nenhuma engenheiro de dados para trabalhar comigo, justamente para mostrar que é possível.
E se tornou um projeto de alto alcance. Foi o primeiro projeto na Pifman que eles tiveram sessenta de margem. Então A Gente Fez Tudo De Forma Eu Fiz Isso Tudo De Forma Gêntica Enfim.
Então, para mostrar para vocês.
Como isso é possível. Que a gente está vendo aqui realidade? Então, na vida real, aqui, nossa.
A gente não tem acesso ao Legacy Coach.
A gente só tem acesso aos Specs. E os Specs te dizem o quê? Entrada.
E saída. Eu não tenho código.
Essa história aqui é bem legal. Depois, quem quiser sentar comigo no bar e saber a história completa.
Não é tão simples assim. Não, mas é que eu não vou gastar tempo aqui falando sobre.
Tá? Mas beleza. Então eu vou receber exatamente como eu recebi. Só pra vocês terem ideia. Isso aqui é um Caso Real Tá Gente, Que Eu Vou Entregar De Novo Tô Viajando Sexta Feira.
Pela terceira vez.
Agora realmente estou entregando essa.
Fase final, a gente entra numa fase de um ano e oito meses de transformação.
E outro esquisito sendo da empresa. E eu vou estar trabalhando com eles também. Nesses próximos tempos.
Top, vocês entenderem, a gente recebia um documento.
Com literalmente algumas informações um pouco complexas. Não vou pegar isso aqui porque é muito complexo. Vamos pegar o ppm, por exemplo.
Você tem diário mensal e assim por diante. Você tem store procedure.
E você tem o Doc.
Que fala desse Star procedure. E você tem.
Na verdade, as tabelas, basicamente isso. Então eu tinha que criar a tradução de Python baseada nisso. E bater com O Valor Real Do Final.
Então, assim.
é para eu mostrar para vocês exatamente o que vocês estão fazendo. é exatamente isso aqui. Eu não tinha acesso ao código.
Fonte de todo o processo, principalmente da parte que fazia mágica.
Ali no processo, a gente vai lidar com os Specs.
Beleza.
Vamos fazer a próxima pergunta.
Pergunta. J, tres, né.
What does refuse the Batch Mean for Source Lie. Então, quando eu tiver uma fonte que mente, né?
Quando eu tiver o arquivo chegando. Que o valor não bate literalmente com o cálculo que a gente vai fazer.
O que a gente vai fazer, né? For Source Lie.
Que pode ser um centavo, por exemplo de diferença. A gente vai fazer o Refuse in the Batch.
O que que significa o Refuse The Batch? Vamos ver, né?
De acordo com aquilo de especificação de modernização. Spec State Cover.
A Batch refuser must adhere to the forming Strict criteria. Então, o que a gente tem que fazer aqui.
Nos Csv is Generated no Business Rules Are Written. Então a gente não gera nenhum Csv.
Nenhuma regra escrita.
A gente.
A falha vai ser escrita como um arquivo de defect.
E a gente vai ter o resto do Pipeline realmente servindo o que você está vendo aqui.
As regras de negócio, certo?
A gente está vendo a regra de negócio aqui?
Basicamente é isso.
Só para vocês entenderem o quão bom.
Vai ser o sistema que a gente vai criar para encapsular isso.
Em um parágrafo. O que é? Planta de legado?
Faz quando eu sanitize o tipo? Um, né.
Qual o processo que ela faz.
Hmm.
E aí, no final.
Vamos perguntar se esses caras contêm.
Ponte de Java.
Então, o que ele falou é o seguinte: durante a ingestão do tipo um daquilo de chegar da planta.
Você tem um processo rígido de privacidade que é feito no arquivo fixo no Sftp.
Fazendo passe disso. No modelo desse arquivo.
Forçando a segurança e a sanitização.
E limpeza do pão e do Cpf.
Para ser tokenizado no Primary Account Number, que é o Pan.
Into a secure Hmec based token.
Então ele vai criar um token extraindo os últimos dígitos e fazendo a mascaração do Cpf também dos últimos dígitos.
E assim por diante. Beleza.
E aqui. Duties Force contém Java Parser.
If I need legacy process to answer say you do not have.
Não, eu não tenho acesso aos parses.
E também não tenho acesso a isso. Então você vai ter que se virar em relação a isso. Então aqui é A Nossa Perspectiva De Um Arquiteto De Solução De Um.
Encher de software recebendo Caraca. Eu não tenho um código fonte.
Até porque a gente vai substituir isso, né? Porque a Turipari Application.
Possam estar muito cara. Ou eles são legados, ou eles não atualizaram o sistema. A gente precisa fazer melhorias em relação a isso.
Então, beleza. Olhamos esse cara agora a gente vai.
No query graph.
Tá? Então aqui a gente vai num prompt.
Né.
Em que ele vai ler.
Esse cara.
E ele vai escrever essas informações aqui.
Então, vamos lá.
Vou fazer isso no repositório.
Então você deve ler o Docs.
Tech. Os dois que nós fizemos, né?
Também tem que ler o contrato no tipo.
E me responder as seguintes perguntas.
O que a gente vai construir.
Que a gente não vai.
E quais são os documentos que são importantes, que difundem do contrato, que não estão corretos com o contrato.
Depois a gente vai perguntar.
Uma informação para a nossa camada de ontologia.
O que significa pago. é diferente.
Que eu tô perguntando? O que é um conceito.
De negócio.
Aqui. Eu estou pedindo uma informação do repositório.
Um reggae. Pode me responder isso? Os documentos podem me receber. Isso.
O que eu perguntar. O que significa? Pago para o tipo um.
Aqui. Eu estou fazendo uma pesquisa. Onde? Na camada de ontologia.
Para perguntar para o catálogo, o que significa pago no contexto? São coisas diferentes. Eu tenho uma informação do negócio.
Ah, então que ele me explica, né?
Contrato. A questão referente ao que eu fiz, né? E os arquivos foram mudados.
Que. Que a gente ia construir. A gente vai construir o tipo um.
A segunda planta vai ler os mesmos bytes e fazer o checkção. A gente tem que basicamente bater com o Java, né?
O resultado final. A gente vai separar isso. De acordo com a arquitetura moderna. E Model Passer, Scheme Right, Handler.
Então a gente vai olhar o consenso dessa informação para poder escrever.
No caminho feliz. A gente vai ter uma validação mínima que é um Steel Thread que vai ter que bater os valores.
O que a gente não vai fazer. Obviamente, a gente vai fazer importação do Java, até porque a gente não vai ter.
A gente não vai transportar o Csv como input, porque a gente vai utilizar para que.
A gente não vai modernizar o Sftp.
A gente não vai usar Dlt hoje. Na verdade, a gente vai focar na arquitetura como um todo.
Quais são os documentos que são evidências, as informações, as limitações e assim por diante.
Agora vamos tentar entender na camada de ontologia, o que significa pago.
Então ele não está disponível. Então ele vai rodar um make ontology para fazer essa pergunta.
Então, basicamente, ele fez essa pergunta, e a ontologia respondeu o seguinte.
O pago por, tipo um vive no reporte Card Settlement Reconciliation. O grão é Bet Id mais currency.
E a procedure. Que escreve ela? Reporting refresh Carmen reconciliation.
Então, basicamente, isso que a gente consegue entender. Do que significa pago para a gente reconstruir.
Esse cara. E aqui ele coloca as informações.
A partir disso, a gente consegue reconstruir.
Esse cara? Porque a gente tem essas documentações aqui.
Então, se a gente vier em Bounding.
As this procedures.
Os samples e os valores esperados. Então a gente vai começar daqui.
Alguma dúvida até aqui.
Certo.
Botei no chat.
Beleza.
Bem. A gente viu no primeiro.
Ontem. Nós vimos.
A parte de captura e a parte de intenção do Converge.
Então esses documentos foram gerados aqui dentro do Docs.
Então a gente tem a intenção inicial, transformando isso num arquivo técnico.
Beleza. O que a gente vai ver hoje? Hoje a gente vai ver mais quatro passos.
Muito, foda. A gente vai estruturar agora os documentos em Adrs.
Posteriormente, a gente vai decompor esse documento, e vocês vão querer entender isso aqui. Essa parte muito interessante.
Depois a gente vai entrar no consensus.
E depois a gente vai criar as folhas de tarefa para serem executadas.
Então é isso que a gente vai fazer hoje.
Para que a nossa Steel thread de transformação do processo.
Tá aqui, ó.
Se a gente for olhar, o converge.
O nosso próximo passo. Como diz aqui.
Executar o Structure. Então, se a gente for no Structure.
Que é esse cara aqui.
O que ele vai fazer? Ele vai pegar o Tech Spec.
E ele vai quebrar isso em decisões.
Por que isso aqui é Foda Small by Chunks. Vocês vão ver exatamente isso. Vocês vão pirar. Então eu estou Pegando Um Documento Gigante Técnico.
Então eu quero que vocês prestem atenção. O que a gente está fazendo desde o início com a Llm. Cara, A Gente, Está Decompondo A Gente Está Reduzindo A Gente Está Trazendo Uma Unidade Menor Granular.
Quanto menor, mais fácil mais modelos podem interagir, menos reasoning fácil, menos token. Eu gasto.
Esse é o Mindset. Tá.
Então.
Vejam que a gente vai estruturar.
Depois a gente vai decompor.
E aqui na parte de decompor. ó.
Na próxima parte.
O que eu vou fazer. Eu vou fazer os requisitos para a Swim Lanes.
Então vou dividir o sistema em planos.
Em linhas de nado.
Nos cortes naturais do sistema.
Para depois a gente entrar no consenso. Quem é o consenso.
O consenso é o adversarial Review.
é o Review adversarial que vai ser usado.
Para verificar se a gente consegue bater consensos.
E depois disso, a gente vai utilizar o Task Spec. A gente vai passar.
Protest Spec. Executar essa atividade.
Sacou.
Então.
Eu deixei separado aqui uma apresentação.
Gigante de Simwise. Mas a gente não vai ter tempo de ver. Ela.
Provavelmente eu leve ela para durante a semana.
Mas a ideia aqui é como a gente vai decompor essa atividade, que é um dos pontos principais de como Que Ele Faz Isso.
Só para vocês entenderem. O Sim Wise é uma parte do converge. Então, pô. Quando eu baixo, converge.
Eu baixo o Ais e baixo o Task Spec. Então, se a gente vier aqui no Converse, por exemplo, o Que Você Vai Conseguir Ver.
Quando você vem no converge.
Aqui é o link do Converge.
Você está vendo aqui que eu tenho uma release do Converge zero dois.
Dentro dessa release.
Eu tenho na verdade. O quê?
Compatibility. Então, do que eu preciso para rodar? O converge.
Então, nesse caso, aqui o que eu tenho do código fonte? Eu preciso do Task Spec. Eu preciso do Simwise Para Poder Fazer Isso Porque.
Porque o sinuais é o cara que entra exatamente na hora da decomposição dessa informação. Quando eu vou fazer esse cara aqui.
Então esse cara aqui é trabalho, basicamente do Simpleise.
Que é fazer a decomposição dessa tarefa.
Que são requisitos para swing learning plans. Eu vou criar um plano de nado.
Em relação a eles e dividir sobre isso aqui. Eu explico um pouco o que significa a decomposição desse carro.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha nele. Na prática.
Então vamos abrir aqui o set.
Sete.
Então, vamos lá.
A primeira coisa que a gente vai fazer é tentar entender um pouquinho sobre esse cara.
Então.
Pedir para ele ler aqui o documento. Presentation spine.
Que eu tenho aqui dentro de Presentation. Tem um Spine aqui? Tá vendo.
Um documento Html, que explica.
De forma bem simples. O que é? O converge.
Então, tem um documento aqui que.
Explica. Eu deixei para vocês disponível para vocês lerem. Eu adoro ler documento assim eu particularmente Luan.
Adoro ler documentos assim.
No avião. Enfim, eu gosto bastante numerar. Então aqui basicamente explica.
Todos os passos do convergem.
O que ele faz, como ele faz. Então estou abrindo para vocês. Algo que nunca foi aberto nem.
Para o Datasip. Inclusive eles vão até me matar. Porque.
A intenção era mostrar para eles.
Não fiquem tristes. A gente vai ter um Deep Dive dentro do nosso programa. Fica tranquilo, tá?
Até porque eu só vou falar sobre isso aqui é gigante. Tem muita coisa.
Mas aqui dá para você aprender, cara. Uma imensidão de técnicas aqui dentro, tá.
Então a gente está inicializando para tentar entender algumas coisinhas aqui.
Então o que eu quero entender? Que ele já respondeu, inclusive tá.
Então, o que é? O converge? O que é Sinwise?
O que é uma linha de corte.
O que significa esses documentos que a gente vai fazer nos passes, tá.
Então converge. é uma espinha.
O Cvg é um portão e o agente é um draft.
Então, os documentos residentes no Docs ou a gente vai executar o passe de dois a quatro depois do cinco.
Não a fábrica ainda. Porque a fábrica vai rodar somente.
Aonde? No quarto e quinto dia.
Então, beleza, síntese. O que o Cvg faz? Então, o Cvg é uma espinha de nove passos, duas fases.
Uma barreira humana.
Ele coordena e nunca escreve.
Código de produto. Ele não intervém.
No dono. Então, quem é o dono? Na verdade, somos nós, tá, então a Cvg é uma cli.
Aonde, basicamente, eu faço a mesma ideia que eu tinha explicado aqui. De todos os meus.
Processo. Então você tem uma interface que anda com o chat como llm.
Que nesse caso, aqui pode ser codecs, né?
Você pode colocar lnime barra Hardness, né? A gente fala bastante hoje.
Então Cloud Code.
Hmm.
Grock aí por aí vai, né.
Beleza. Então, basicamente, isso.
Esse cara. Carrega uma Skill que carrega uma cli beleza.
Onde estava?
Estava okay.
Não, não estava em nenhum deles. Estava aqui.
Beleza. Então ele capta esse cara. O agente faz o Gate de selar. E o que o sinuais é, né?
Então, se o Einstein. Eles são as linhas, né?
Ele corta o sistema. Ele cria Swim Lens. Ele cria o Legs. Vocês vão entender. Agora.
A segunda Indian faz a decomposição.
E aí exatamente esse processo de decomposição que a gente vai ver no Silhuides.
Aí o que a gente tem? Qual mínimo viável de um produto dentro desse corte? é o que a gente Chama De Steel Thread.
Que é exatamente o mínimo viável para a criação. Que a gente vai testar exatamente esse processo.
E aqui explica um pouquinho quais são os passos que a gente vai fazer. O que vai acontecer nesse cara.
E é basicamente isso.
Vocês vão colocando qualquer dúvida aqui dentro do repositório. Vamos para o oito, né?
Que é o próximo. Então a gente vai entender a estrutura agora vai ficar bem legal.
Imagina um parado que faz tudo isso automaticamente para você, né? Então imagine um tanto de tempo que foi gasto refinando.
Esses caras, cara. Um bom tempo. Viu?
Muito tempo. Então, ó.
Vamos lá. O que a gente vai executar aqui?
A gente vai executar o terceiro passe. Na verdade, o passe doze, porque o primeiro passo é o passe zero.
Então você é o passe Ii da estrutura do nothing human led no product code.
Eu quero que você leia o documento que a gente gerou.
Que é o documento técnico.
E daí? O que ele vai fazer?
Literalmente usa a Skill para fazer o próximo passo. Então, basicamente, o que eu estou fazendo.
é chamar esse cara aqui? Essa Skill.
Então, quando eu falo, passe dois, ele automaticamente entende que existe uma Skill atrelada a isso.
Executa Celai e vamos ver o que ele vai fazer com essa informação. Tá.
Então ele vai ler estrutura inteira, e ele vai criar os Doc Adrs e o Context Md.
Olha que lindo, né? Então você vai ver. Na verdade, o que ele vai fazer é, ele vai.
Criar uma pasta de Adrs.
Ele vai começar a jogar. Quais são os Adrs aqui? E aí? Vamos entrar aqui nessas especificidades, enquanto ele cria Aqui Que é Interessante.
Quero mostrar uma coisa para vocês. Aqui.
Aqui. ó.
Toda vez que você passa pelo converge.
O que eu quero garantir é que toda decisão que ela é feita. Ela é gravada. Uma Id.
E o fato de a gente construir esse Idr e passar essa informação no contexto é o seguinte.
Eu escrevo várias coisas que vão acontecer no projeto. Quais são os pontos principais? E toda vez que eu tenho Uma L Que Vai Fazer Uma Pesquisa No Repositório.
Ele vai primeiro pelo contexto. Torne D.
Ele vai carregar isso. E ele vai entender. Domínio Glossário.
Termo, o que significa o que foi falado, o que não foi feito e assim por diante.
Então, basicamente, os Adrs são literalmente registros ou fatos.
Que contém informações e evidências, sempre uma evidência.
Esse aqui é uma melhor prática de arquitetura que sempre foi usada há muito tempo. Então, se você vê aqui.
What is an avr. Você vê, na verdade que é obviamente.
Haiti, né.
Arquitetura decision record. Então.
é um documento de decisão de arquitetura que guarda várias informações e provas sobre isso.
Então, quando eu chamo o, converge.
Ele começa a fazer isso aqui.
Exatamente.
Ele é uma referência. A gente vai ver aqui agora. Então, ó.
First write is Landing Park. Olha que lindo. Foi. Aceito.
Qual é o contexto? Qual é a decisão.
O que não é. Qual a consequência e qual a evidência? Qual a evidência apontando para o local.
Tipo dois. Tipo, é tipo um Five File Package.
Então o que ele é, o que ele não é. O que ele vai ter que fazer. As evidências que Ele Foi Feito Depois.
Démal Never float. Olha só. Que foda.
Então ele falou: Cara, a gente sempre vai usar desse mal e nunca floate. Depois.
Privacy dies at the parser explica que a privacidade vai morrer aqui. Que a gente tem que fazer a obifuscação depois.
Quando o Source Lies, quando eu tenho um problema na fonte, o que a gente vai fazer? Tudo que a Gente Vê Nos Documentos A Gente Já Está Fazendo Isso Pra Gente Automaticamente.
Está quebrando e criando tudo isso para a gente. Tá.
Later Night Questions. O que ele vai fazer do plano? O que ele vai criar, que são as Adrs que foram feitas.
E aqui ele te mostra basicamente o que foi feito.
O que é goçado. E é isso. Por exemplo, se eu vir aqui em Docs Context.
O que eu tenho aqui. ó.
Eu tenho um contexto inteiro, inclusive o Match pokok.
Pensa no converge, tá? Só pra vocês entenderem o nível aqui da apelação que eu fiz. Tá.
Conve tem tudo de todos. Então, o que significa isso aqui? Se você vier aqui dentro do Skills Agents.
Imagina que todos esses caras que existem aqui. Eu varri todos eles.
E eu adimei todas as práticas de brainstorming do Match Pokock, de Grill e de Wayfinder.
De Spec Definition.
Hendoff de triagem de tudo que a gente tem.
Dos duzentos maiores. Então eu fiz uma pesquisa em duzentos mais feitas de download, e trouxe para dentro do convert. Todos eles.
Técnica de injeção de Prompt, otimização, contexto, tudo isso.
Built. Uma série de técnicas aqui dentro.
Uma delas é, por exemplo, uma das coisas que construir. Engenheiro de software, que é o glossário que te diz a referência.
Então aqui você tem tudo velho. é muito foda Overpunch. Nos últimos dígitos decimal que é. Então eu crio.
Uma cadeia.
De contexto para ele entender.
E isso é limitado automaticamente no converge. Tá.
Sim, só no chat, tá.
Do jeito que eu criei. Só no chat que você trabalha. Tudo ele.
Então ele criou esses documentos. Agora, para mim, a parte mais foda que vocês vão ver que é uma das Coisas Que Eu Faço.
Quase sempre que me arrepia até hoje. Tá, então, beleza.
Geramos os Avrs.
Agora a gente vai cortar os Sims. Isso aqui é importante vocês entenderem.
Deixa. Eu vim aqui. Nove.
A gente não precisa passar esse Prompt para ele, tá.
é só passar assim. ó.
Should, ver se ele instalou aqui. Só um minut.
Não sei porque ele não está aparecendo aqui como package. Deixa eu ver.
Deve ser um problema. Deve ser um problema desse cara. Deixa eu abrir aqui.
Deixa eu abrir uma nova Tab, deixa eu chamar aqui o Codec.
Deixa eu dar aqui um.
Converge.
Eu não sei o que ele está aparecendo aqui.
Mas quando você chamar no seu llm.
Ele tem que aparecer como um comando aqui para a gente, tá.
Sempre como um comando para poder te dar. Eu não sei o que está aparecendo. Depois eu vou ver. Deve Ser Algum Tipo De.
Problema na integração, mas é para vocês verem. Então você simplesmente não precisa passar nesse nível. Chat.
Você pode simplesmente só fazer arroba.
Tal passe tres e acabou automaticamente. Ele entende de onde você parou.
Teoricamente, a mesma ideia lá do Agent Spec, para quem já usou spec privately development.
Um vai alimentando o outro.
Então, só para vocês entenderem.
Só um minutinho. Só anotar aqui para poder ver o que aconteceu.
Please. We'll take it.
César vendo luaná. Espero que se você tiver múltiplas reuniões. Mas em uma reunião mais recente, decidido algo que anulou Decisões Passadas Como Se Atualizado No Século De Brain.
Aqui. Não seria esse conceito de Second Brain. Mas o que você vai receber quando você receber um novo documento, Vamos Supor Um Novo Documento.
Você vai passar por dentro dos passos do converge e automaticamente ele vai datar essa informação.
E vai atualizar aqui, tá.
E vai botar essa informação dentro.
Dele. Deixa eu ver se ele já.
Ainda não.
Ele vai criar uma pasta internamente converge, ó.
Deixa eu ver se consigo abrir aqui. Cbg.
Aqui. ó Cadê.
é aqui.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo mostrar pra vocês.
Todo envolto do projeto.
Deixa eu ver se eu vou lembrar aqui.
Aqui. Acho que está aqui.
Aqui. ó, então dentro da estrutura.
Dentro da estrutura do converge.
Você tem automaticamente um cérebro que vai.
Entendendo todos os passes que vão acontecendo. Ele vai coletando essas informações internamente na estrutura dele.
Então ele vai construindo um próprio Second Brain para você.
Dos contextos do que você injeta nele.
Aí. A gente tem aqui.
Toda parte de documentos. E aí ele quebra ainda mais. O que que é no gol? O que é Text Pack O Que Eles São.
Então ele vai aprendendo com esse cara.
Aí eu tenho. Como ele vai quebrar.
O Swim Lenes. Então isso é a estrutura interna do que ele utiliza. Então ele tem várias técnicas de memorizar, de aprender.
De entender. Porque na próxima vez que você trabalha com ele, já atualiza o Bren, ele já sabe o que Precisa Ser Feito Assim Por Diante Tá.
Então, só passando um tempo aí.
Namorando ele para vocês entenderem, até porque depois eu vou fazer um Master Class de dois dias.
Sobre o converge, tá.
Ensinando internos realmente como ele é, por que ele funciona, como é feito assim por diante.
Mas não agora, beleza. Então, aqui em Doc só gerou os Abrs.
E aí ele gerou. Sims, tá vendo?
Então, olha só que importante isso aqui. Sims, tá.
Então, o que ele gerou aqui.
O que é um sim? Passe três de decompor. Sim, ele quebra em cima. Swim Lane e Legs.
Então o sim é o hand off, não a linguagem.
A gente vai sempre criar um Steel Thread.
Que é uma thread muito importante, que é do tipo um.
This is the only.
Lane for leaves tonight. Essa é a única linha que a gente vai criar hoje.
Que vai provar o nosso processo.
Então a lista de síndos que a gente vai cortar aqui.
O. Sim. Swim Lane.
Quando que consome o que não escreve como ele, que termina essas Legs como ele faz. Então a gente vai ver.
Toda essa estrutura, como ele já está procedendo. Como ele vai quebrar o sistema para a gente. Eu vou mostrar agorinha para vocês.
Então eu criei os cortes do sistema.
Beleza.
O que que é o sim, o corte, o que é consumido, o que é produtivizado.
Quem escreve o que é um Sullen.
Exatamente quem.
é dono de uma posição. Coordena a surface de escrita.
Para que os outros possam ter contratos. Então, basicamente, ele pega o entendimento do contexto inteiro.
Ele acha. Quais são os cortes do sistema, por exemplo, para ficar simples. Front end backend data. E ai não é bem assim.
Talvez só como forma de explicação.
E assumem lenes. Que ele vai fazer dentro desses cortes? Ele vai especificar quais são as características do que é Paralelo Do Que é Serial.
De como eu corto. Qual a referência disso?
E dentro do Swing Lanes. Ele vai gerar as Legs que a gente vai ver exatamente.
Agora.
E as Lags. Nesse caso, aqui a gente não vai gerar, porque a gente só gerou Steel Thread. Tá.
Mas as lag na verdade é quando você tem um sub item deles. Deixa eu te mostrar aqui.
Por exemplo, nesse cara. Então o que é uma lag? Então aqui, ó Swim Lanes, ele quebrou em Assurance Foundation Models Então Se Eu Abrir Em Models Tá Vendo.
Eu tenho a Lane. Então, ó Swim Lane Models.
Então tem aqui. Ele desenha com a arquitetura. Quais são as referências que eu tenho em cima disso? Como que ele quebra.
E aí eu tenho as pernas. Tá vendo?
Então, quais são as pernas? Swim Lane, Models Lag, um staging.
Então ele fala apresentar fontes, declarada e assim por diante, o que prova o que é independente, o que consome.
Quais são as informações? Isso aqui vai virar uma tarefa ou várias tarefas. Então, a partir disso, aqui.
Ele vai entrar. O Task Spec vai entrar posteriormente a isso. Vai entender.
Essa lag e dessa Lag, ele vai transformar numa tarefa atômica. Vocês vão ver durante a semana, tá? Eu não Vou Entrar Em Detalhes Aqui Porque Vocês Vão Ver.
Durante a semana. Tudo isso aqui.
Beleza. A gente tem esse cara agora.
Nosso próprio. Agora é.
Consensos, né? Então a gente vai agora para o passe quatro.
O passe quatro. A gente quebrou aqui em planos. O passe quatro é um adversarial.
Então, quando o usuário usa um review adversarial consensos, isso aqui não é opcional. Está vendo.
Essa primeira parte zero é opcional quando você tem vários documentos, e você já não tem a ideia de um Documento Que Você Recebeu às Vezes Você Já Recebe Um Documento Fixo.
De negócio se transforma. Ele.
Aqui. Vocês vejam que não é opcional.
Então, o que ele ia fazer quando o usuário usa um review adversarial. Um consensus. Ele ataca o plano.
Tem um outro modelo para refutar e faz o sinoff. Ele não escreve.
Novos planos ou corta tarefas. Ele simplesmente tem que chegar no consenso.
Então, o que a gente vai fazer aqui.
O próximo passo.
O passo do consenso.
Eu posso chamar ele? Como eu posso dar um Cvg com senso? Sign Jason.
Para poder fazer o consenso desse cara.
E assim por diante.
Aí o que eu tenho configurado aqui para dentro desse consenso. Então vou dar uma olhada aqui. O que eu Tenho Diante De Consenso.
Hoje, dentro do consenso.
Eu utilizo. Na verdade.
E eu estou para mudar isso aqui, né? Porque quando eu criei, ele utilizava cloud como backbone.
Então, o Cloud hoje tem uma Skill que ele chama o adversário.
E ele pode utilizar o default como Codex para fazer isso. Esse é o default. Existe um plugin no Cloud.
Que é como você consegue invocar de forma transparente o códex. Para fazer isso, eu criei também um plugin.
Que eu uso bastante.
Que é o Plugin.
Que eu acho que está aberto no meu repositório. Inclusive.
Tá aberto. Tá aberto. Tá aqui. Quem quiser usar.
Então, o que ele faz aqui? O que esse Plugin faz esse cara? Na verdade, ele é um plugin.
Do Cloud Code para o Kimi.
Então você instala ele como plugin.
Do Cloud. E daí você coloca a sua assinatura via Acp.
E basicamente você tem agora esse tipo de coisa que você pode fazer controlada pelo Cloud. Então você pode dar um review.
Você pode dar um desafio. Você pode dar um expor a codebase. Você pode dar um cranking para executar tarefas. Olha O Task Spec Aqui.
Você pode dar um Crank Bat para executar várias tarefas. Você pode dar um Crank next para.
Executar tarefas em prioridade diferente. Você pode gerar um plano com ele.
Então você usa basicamente o Kimi.
Dentro do Cloud. Então o Cloud controla o Kimi.
Então a gente utiliza esse Skill aqui também dele. Na prática, o que vai acontecer aqui em grande escala.
Quando eu der um Cvg, consenso Sign Jason, né.
Vamos ver se consigo fazer esse cara aqui.
Então.
Ele não está instalado, tá.
O que ele vai fazer. Ele vai chegar num consenso que eu estou executando a Clay.
E esse consenso aqui, na prática, realmente, que vai acontecer.
Deixa eu ver se isso é do Codex.
é isso mesmo. é o da própria Openai.
Ele mesmo. Então, basicamente, eu usei ele para criar o do Kimi. Só que o meu está mais completo. Eu Gastei Mais Tempo Nele.
E o que esse Consensus faz, né? Só para vocês.
Verem aqui em detalhe.
Ele vai refutar por padrão pontos em que a gente não pegou. Então vamos fazer o melhor. Vamos chamar esse cara.
E aí? Nesse caso, a gente vai executar.
O pesquatro.
Provavelmente ups errado. Provavelmente porque eu estou.
No Grok. Quero ver inclusive como ele vai ver que eu notei no Groc. Ainda.
Eu uso ele no codec ou uso ele no Cloud. Eu nunca usei ele no.
No Groc. Então vai ser bom pra gente ver.
Como ele vai fazer isso?
Todo mundo seguindo aí. Vocês estão executando.
Agora só estão no modelo, prestando atenção.
O que vocês estão recebendo aí de resultado.
Boa. Preste atenção, porque depois vocês podem executar também na sequência, os.
Os Rans são todos ali. Se podem executar a tarde.
Ah, que legal. Olha só. Que bonitão. O Marcelo mandou.
Olha aí.
Bonitão, hein, Caraca.
Hum Legal.
Ele tá atacando aqui, né?
Huh? Save Hardwired, Lane Street in stock and the rappic and dispatch.
é porque o padrão pediu para colocar no Docs. Na verdade, o padrão dele é dentro do Cvg.
Reviews fica dentro de swing lanes. Mas ele não respeitou. Inclusive isso. é uma coisa interessante de pegar aqui.
Vamos ver o que ele gerou. Aí. Ele está aqui. Executando esse cara, né?
Acho que agora ele vai fechar.
Oh, I couldn't go to you.
Ele tocou alguma coisa? Taskask, Helena e o Record Gates Results object consensus.
Ele vai criar um Doc chamado Consensus. Aqui.
Docs consensus. Dot, Md.
Beleza. Consensus do R and D.
O que que ele teve aqui. Tá, então. Barreira, docs.
Assinalado, Data. O que a gente executou.
Blah, blá, blá, contradição.
Aí. Isso aqui é pra gente revisar o meio da marina.
De Star. Ela não mandou.
Fermento. Bound Pack deve declarar a computação quarenta e cinco. Jud.
Manter esse cara aqui. ó objeções, promoções, objeções que nós temos.
Perguntas abertas.
Sign off aqui. Eu estou executando o Convention de uma forma mais aberta, tá.
Mas quando a gente executar ele num processo fixo, mesmo ele não vai deixar a gente passar de passo a Passo Se Ele Não Fizer O Grilling.
Então porque vocês vão ver? Na verdade, é que.
Existem várias. Quando você abrir. Deixa eu ver se eu consigo abrir aqui.
Beleza. Se vocês executarem Cvg.
Vocês vão ver uma cacetada de coisa. Tá, então aqui, ó.
Isso tudo é o que a Clay.
Impossibilita você, cara. é gigante. Sei lá. Tá.
Uma das coisas que a Selic possibilita é todo o passe que você vai fazer.
Você vai adicionar alguns checks que você tem. Então você tem cheque de grills? Você tem cheque de intent. Você Tem Vários Tipos De Coisa Na Socied.
De materialização, tá? Então tem um bocado de coisa aqui dentro para vocês explorarem, que eu só estou dando um grasping.
Porque senão a gente não consegue sair, né?
Então, beleza, o que ele fez.
Sin is Helena diaz canonco refusing stay on design do not start Past Five and assignment.
Uma. Assinar esse documento com o Luan.
Mas se a gente consegue, vamos ver se o Cvg deixa eu assinar ele. Ela recomendou assinar como Helena. Obviamente não.
Helena que mandou os requisitos para a gente.
A gente vai assinar como Luan. Então eu estou assinando como Luan, que é uma das coisas obrigatórias do passe.
Todos nós chegamos ao consenso que, no mínimo, é. Eu.
Aylene que eu tô conversando. E uma Llm.
Fora, né?
E daí? A gente vai executar agora o Task Spec. Então.
Na quinta parte.
Olha só. Que legal!
Então, na quinta parte, aqui, inclusive escrito stand Alone.
O que a gente vai fazer. A gente vai querer escrever um Task Spec.
Então, se a gente clicar aqui, ele manda.
Eu pro Task Spec. Tá vendo?
Que está aberto para vocês também.
E aí, nesse Task Spec.
O que eu vou fazer? Você está no passe cinco.
Você basicamente vai escrever uma tarefa olhando no Doc.
Vai escrever dentro do Tasks.
E você vai usar o documento que a gente criou anteriormente do Swim Lanes.
Pegar esse cara aqui.
Vamos vir aqui.
Assinei consensos como eu. Então, foi aceitado por mim.
Da aula. E agora a gente vai.
Criar essa tarefa atômica via Task Spec. Então ele vai ler os Docs.
Vai entender que eu tenho Sims. E vai criar Steel threads.
Que é a menor.
Das atividades para a gente escrever esse cara. Fim. Enfim.
O que ele vai fazer aqui.
Olha que interessante. Aqui.
Você não. Como ele faz isso? Cvg Test, Spec.
Bin está tentando inicializar o Task Spec.
Sain off carregou a Skill.
Para dentro da Llm.
Chamou um sub agente para poder fazer.
Leu assim? Tá vendo?
Já entender o que ele vai ter que fazer. Como ele vai quebrar. Então ele vai olhar.
As lags aqui.
Todo mundo morreu. Pessoal, estão comigo?
Ah, então, beleza. Boa.
Esperando com aparelhos. é.
Beleza. Um ponto importante aqui.
Luan. A gente poderia fazer de outra forma. Com certeza.
Mas no final das coisas, tudo iriam transbordar para que você chegasse a um ponto desse.
Pegar um problema muito grande.
Quebrai um documento em pedaços de documento.
Depois pegar e se transformar numa forma técnica de você compilar e escrever isso e depois pedir.
Para alguém executar tudo isso.
Isso aqui é diferente de você abrir o Codecs e falar o seguinte. Esse é o problema. Escreve o ambiente todo. Sair.
Você não tem nenhum tipo de garantia. Você não tem nenhum tipo de voz. Você não tem nenhum tipo de Loop Você Não Tem Nenhum Tipo De Microtarfa.
Você não consegue ver o que foi criado? Quais foram as decisões feitas? Por que foi feita.
Então você precisa de um framework hoje. A llm meio que é um black box. Eu posso chegar e falar pô beleza.
Eu tenho esse projeto tal tal especifica, ele inteiro. Vá, não sei o que tal.
Gera um plano. Aí ele gera um plano gigantesco para você, tá? Ele executa o plano.
E ele vai fazer.
Só que tem vários buracos.
Que vão acontecer. E segundo, é uma Black Box. Você não consegue saber o que está sendo executado.
Então, o que basicamente a gente está fazendo? A gente está forçando a Llm a executar passo a passo.
Para mim. Pegar uma coisa grande.
Diminuir, ela criar o requisito.
De criar o documento de requisitos.
Criar o documento técnico.
Quebrar esse documento técnico em, literalmente decisões de registros arquiteturais que são extremamente certos.
Depois pegar. Baseado nessas informações.
Criar as linhas de corte do sistema para a gente poder trabalhar e diminuir mais suas decomposição.
Depois pegar essas informações.
E quebrar elas em atividades atômicas pequenas para serem executadas. Então é isso que a gente está fazendo.
Beleza deu para entender, né?
Daqui a pouco. Aqui a gente vai ver, na verdade. O quê?
Esse cara escrevendo uma tarefa pra gente.
E daí que vem a parte mais interessante que é o meu amor.
A minha relação de amor e amor.
Com o Desk Spec. Então.
Já. Já. Aparece aqui uma nova.
Um folder chamado Test, que eu pedi tudo.
Por padrão. Ele vai escrever dentro de um Cvg e ele vai ter todas as informações organizadinhas. Tá.
Mas aqui eu estou pedindo para ele escrever dentro do Docs. Ele vai escrever todas as informações para a gente dentro do Docs.
Perguntas. O bagulho é louco. é aqui. é o bagulho. é bem louco. Viu.
Aqui. A economia de tempo, cara. é outra brincadeira. Então, assim.
Vida real. Peguei o problema.
Peguei vários documentos, destrinchei.
Rodeio converge a primeira parte.
Segunda, definir o requisito. O documento técnico. Aí fui lá. Trouxe o Simwise. Cortei.
Os sistemas. Pedir para gerar as Tasks. Olha isso. Meu Deus!
Ele vai lá e vai começar a gerar as tasks para mim.
Beleza aí. Olha só. Que loucura. O que eu faço na curve. Eu venho aqui nas Tasks.
Eu tenho test abertas aqui. Tá vendo?
Tudo que eu faço no sistema. Ele cria tarefas para serem executadas.
Mas não somente isso. Eu tenho aqui um Ci, uma automação que toda.
Todo dia, duas horas da manhã. Ele executa e passa em cima dessas tarefas para ver o que precisa ser Executado E O Que Ele Não Precisa.
Então você tem uma fábrica autônoma, bicho.
Que vai passando por isso fazendo. Então eu estou mostrando para vocês o que é canônico para vocês utilizarem nesses projetos de vocês.
Ele definiu inclusive já uma tarefa aqui. Se eu não me engano, aqui.
Meu Deus, hein.
Que coisa linda. Deixa eu abrir esse cara.
Aqui. Eu quero que vocês vejam.
Tá aqui. ó, o que tem uma tarefa.
Tá agora? Por que ele não me mostrou Front matter.
Está feio. Esse filme de meter cara.
Está bem feito. Anti metro, aqui.
Deixa eu abrir. Aonde? Open file.
Não. Open File.
Tá.
Vamos lá. Vamos ler.
Deixa eu só esperar ele acabar.
Vamos virar vendas em dinheiro fazendo isso, rapaz. Isso converge. Opera bolsa de Valores. Tá lindo com o claudinho.
Abrir novinho. Só que não.
Deixa eu só esperar ele terminar de assinalar a primeira tarefa.
Só para a gente ver a força desse cara em grande escala.
State lock. Beleza.
Aqui. Eu tenho um State.
Que ele vai movendo. Então aqui eu tenho, por exemplo, a revisão. E aí, obviamente, a gente não vai entrar no detalhe, mas.
O Task Spec garante que ninguém vai.
Quebrar o selo de uma tarefa. Então a tarefa é selada.
Com o chá que eu tenho uma chave privada.
E na hora em que esse cara é assinalado e passado para uma agente, ele fecha essa chave. Hit mec.
Então, se alguém tentar interferir nessa execução, ou se houver, temper de tentar alguém abrir ou tentar fazer ele.
Ele falha. A Taref.
Ele não segue.
Aqui tem. E aí, a parte mais foda de todos é que vocês vão ver exatamente. Quero que acabe aqui Justamente Para Vocês Verem.
O que tem dentro da tarefa, só para você expirarem um pouquinho. O que eu construí dentro dessa tarefa atômica. De fato.
Aí valer a pena.
Beleza está aqui.
Botou aqui uma descrição do que é tarefa, né?
E inclusive uma coisa que eu não falei para vocês que eu falar nessa.
Nessa semana que vocês vão pirar.
Que é o Task Mesh.
é extremamente novo. Eu vou publicar para vocês. Vocês vão ter acesso ao Taskmash também. Essa semana.
Mas enfim, vamos lá abrir essa tarefa aqui.
Então, o que tem nessa tarefa? Ela tem o Front Matter.
Então isso aqui é o que carrega na hora que a Llm passa.
Para entender se ela precisa carregar isso para a memória ou não. Para carregar para dentro do contexto dela ou não.
Tá. é.
A edita tarefa: título.
Se ela está pronta. Qual formato? Qual o profile aqui? Existem um bilhão de configurações, tá? Você vai ter que Navegar Dentro Task Spec Para Saber.
Ele já vai gerar para você um esforço. Small Medium ou large.
Eh, extra small, small Medium large extra large Xl. Excel.
Xr extra Watch tá? Quantas interações de budget posso fazer? São quinze interações. Depois ela.
Simplesmente para. Posso ter qualquer agente para fazer isso. Parente? Depende do que se é subscrita.
O que toca agora. Olha, parte.
Olha a parte do Hardness aqui embedada.
Ela vai criar um Pf chamado quê? Creates Path Modern Ingestion Src nothing type card settlement sports pi.
Source documents.
Quais são as tags? Quem é o Walner? Qual tipo de prioridade.
Qual é a severidade crítica financeira.
Quais são as pré condições? Bloqueada.
Classe de segurança e Restricted Synthetic Pi. Já identificou.
Qual é a fonte? Se foi rastreada, se foi assinada, para quem? Ainda não. Enfim, tá. O que ele explica dentro da atividade.
Agora eu quero ver se vocês estão realmente entendendo o contexto como um todo. Tá.
Então passer types um core serumendente decimo privacy safe record for landing why.
Privacy dies at the Parcelmonies Decimo. Lembra? Qr fala que o dinheiro sempre décimo.
This is the first modern right.
Que é determinístico para que sobre o Modern Landing nunca é Sftp. Beleza, esse aqui é o contexto principal.
Do que a tarefa. Olha só isso. Aqui. Gol.
Calma aí, Luan. Você tem um loop dentro da tarefa. é exatamente. Eu uso isso aqui pra lupar dentro da tarefa.
Objetivo. O autor tem que executar o tipo. Um ponto Dat, que vão ficar o Sagner Over. Punching decimal de Escala O Token Com Vinte E Quatro E Manter Tal Tal.
Com os últimos dias para a publicação no paqueta, mantendo o valor. Não escreve no Legacy contract, tal.
Não escreve no modern no product code. Somente se tiver dá um site sign it off igual falso.
Qual é o contexto?
It's still threat. Tipo um. A gente está testando baseado no Sim, no contrato que a gente vai escrever o Consenso Feito Por Mim.
Manter as informações. Qual é o comportamento? Qual é o primeiro comportamento.
While. O que é isso? Isso aqui é loop Engineering.
Context Engineering, Behavioral Engineering, Bdd. Qual é o comportamento que eu quero.
Dado um tipo. Um.
Quando o passe fizer isso, então faz isso. Ele vai transformar isso em linha de código no meu Tdd. Também.
Quando, tipo, um for fazer isso, então terminar isso, fizer isso quando for assim, então é assim. Tal.
Então, Behavior, qual é o critério de sucesso? Cada critério é executável.
Olha só isso aqui. Então ele tem um critério de execução.
O que é isso? Ele vai basicamente.
Verificar. Ele vai fazer um inválogo para ver se o decimal está feito.
Ele vai verificar se o layout está correto.
Se ele pega as informações e retorna.
A segunda primeiro, ficar a privacidade dos últimos dígitos.
Depois a gente tem aqui.
Qual é o tipo de grapping que ele vai fazer? O que ele vai fazer.
Aqui a gente tem validação. De onde está o arquivo? Se ele vai conseguir acessar o Pf lá do Sftp para fazer isso.
Outrival. Que ele vai fazer aqui?
Ele vai cilar o Spec e vai verificar se o arquivo está aqui. Enfim.
Somente se ele passar nesses evolu aqui.
Ele vai fazer uma verificação no cartão. Ele vai verificar. Pô.
Beleza. Esses são os iguais de verde ou vermelho?
Mas agora eu tenho um cartão de validação desses caras.
Então eu falo o seguinte: evol um.
O Iva um vai fazer um passe no nível decimal.
Para verificar se esse passe está certo.
é uma Task. Só é um Steel Thread.
Acontece que só então a descrição é o quê? O tipo de humano é decimal. Escala dois. Então ele vai Comparar Isso Com A Linguagem Natural Para Verificar Se é.
é becha determiníssico e atende o comportamento terminal. Sim.
E tem uma espera de cinco segundos, no máximo de duração cadival.
é determinístico. é determinística, é determinístico.
Quais são as regras de Heat Try.
Quais são os contratos que eu tenho assinados? O que ele vai fazer.
O sindbox que ele vai fazer. Se existe alguma dependência, qual é o critério de saída? Qual o plano de Hobeck.
Quais são os Hooks de observabilidade que ele vai fazer aqui? Eu conecto com, por exemplo, Langfusion para poder fazer.
Quais são os antipadrões.
O que você não vai tocar. E quais são as perguntas? Ou seja, eu desenvolvi uma indignie.
Que faz tudo isso aqui? ó.
Então, em vez de utilizar, em vez de pensar.
De fora. Para dentro.
Eu quis pensar de dentro para fora.
Então eu quis criar um processo onde a tarefa.
é o maior corpo e o corpo mais importante. Então, Peskspec, olha a tarefa de dentro para fora.
Então ele utiliza um modelo.
Ele já tem um prompt embedado com uma especificação lá dentro.
Ele possui o contexto da tarefa. Ele tem um Harness do que ele vai fazer. E o binding do que Ele Vai Fazer Em Qual Ambiente Ele Vai Estar.
Ele tem um loop com o objetivo que ele vai fazer. Ele tem os humanos e máquina que faz.
E ele tem o grafo que faz todo o desenho pelo test match que eu vou mostrar amanhã.
Que é um grupo de atividades, executando em várias escalas diferentes. Então ele tem tudo dentro de uma tarefa.
é uma tarefa atômica.
Que é executada para isso. E ela foi gerada aqui.
Beleza.
Muito doido isso aqui, né.
Muito e oito.
E aqui meu irmão. Só quem é curioso vai saber, né?
Que aí aqui. Eu vou deixar várias pesquisas aqui para vocês fazerem. Então a gente criou a primeira tarefa.
A gente não vai executar ou vai executar. Então vamos pegar o seguinte. Let S.
Crank, this task.
Let's Crank the test.
Aí. Você pode falar. Pum.
Aqui. Eu estou fazendo manual. Depois a gente vai ver.
Então estou pedindo para ele escrever essa tarefa. Vamos lá ver se ele vai escrever. Agora é a parte da loucura.
But pequena, bem declarada, específica.
Então vamos ver aqui o que o Grok falou.
Então ele vai começar a implementação dessa tarefa.
Enquanto isso, vamos voltar aqui, que depois a gente abre para perguntas. Já já.
Então, basicamente, o que a gente fez, né?
A gente decompôs essa tarefa.
E trouxe ela para o mínimo detalhe. Então, uma folha, um Evol. O Evol está dentro da tarefa. Boom.
Então isso aqui foi um trabalho cara que eu gastei muito tempo de tentar colapsar e trazer todas as melhores Práticas De Engenharia Gente, Que Eu Num Framework Num Processo.
Vocês conseguem ver o que a gente está criando aqui? Sim ou não? Coloquem no chat. A gente já está Acabando Tá A última Energia Do Dia Prometo.
Vocês conseguem entender o que tem dentro dessa especificação. Como um todo.
A gente tem tudo dentro de uma tarefa. Então eu estou olhando a tarefa como o nosso centro.
Como nosso cor.
E o nosso core gera.
Então, basicamente, eu estou destilando, decompondo um problema até chegar para ele e falar. Cara cria uma tarefa para mim.
Ele vai criar essa tarefa exatamente com o menor núcleo possível.
E lá dentro dessa tarefa, a gente vai ter todas as regras para criar. Ela.
Ela tem um looping dentro dessa tarefa. Ela tem.
As regras dessa tarefa têm os Evals dessa tarefa. Ela tem um contexto para aquela tarefa.
Ou seja, eu posso chamar qualquer engine para poder fazer isso.
Quer ver uma parada muito foda.
Tá. é.
Vou abrir para vocês aqui. Uma coisa bem legal. Tá.
Então vou vir aqui.
Do comitá.
Mostrar uma coisa aqui.
O que eu criei. O Task Spec.
é por causa disso que eu vou mostrar agora.
Deixa eu puxar.
Tá aqui. ó, o meu repositório está atualizado. Tá.
Eu vou criar uma Work Tree.
Hoje. Vocês estão vendo Task Spec e o Simwise.
Aberto. Amanhã a gente vai entrar. Qual é a grande dica.
Que eu daria para vocês, né?
Eu viria aqui dentro do nosso notebook. Lm.
Eu viria em adicionar uma fonte.
E aí, obviamente, eu viria aqui.
Task Spec.
Pegaria esse cara viria aqui dentro? Colaria aqui dentro. Daria.
Tal. E estaria também no converge.
E daria também no. Sim, Wise.
Então pegaria esses três aqui e colocaria no contexto.
Pensar de forma inteligente. Comeon guys.
E vim aqui. E Puppe.
Trazer esses caras para cá.
E daí? Eu vou criar um novo notebook.
Na verdade, não.
Errado querer errado, My Badge? Fui menino.
Beleza. Ele tem um contexto aqui.
E aí, o que a gente faz? A gente pode vir agora.
E eu começaria a literalmente.
Explorar.
Vamos ver aqui.
Olha só. Faz sentido decompor tarefas para Llm. Sim, é essencial.
Largely language models.
Performam melhor, alucinam menos e escreve significativamente melhor código quando trabalham com Highly Bounded Atomic Context.
According to Coverage framework core architecture principles seems wise the compose task spec contracts converge coordinates.
Avoids big bank failure modes isolates blast radius enforce consensus and provide clear objective criterias.
Check a Task Spec.
Generated.
And give a rate on the quality.
Of the structure.
For Any Frontier or Open weight Model.
To crank.
Desk Based on the Task.
Spec.
Configuration.
Spec go and test spect.
Five.
Vamos dar uma olhadinha aqui.
Enquanto ele faz isso. O que eu quero mostrar para vocês. Isso aqui.
Miserável criou, né?
Em dentro de Modern.
Ingestion, Src Oil Mouse Project.
Vindo! Types One.
Parcer. Nossa. Mas que código feio! Luan.
Puta que pariu, né.
Bem. O que é depressivo? é isso aqui.
A parte do foda lá ele mil vezes. é esse aqui. ó, eu vou abrir um Work Tree.
Totalmente separado.
Aonde não existe.
Esse cara criado? Porque ele está dentro do Modern. Eu não tenho Modern ainda. Eu fiz o cheque. Ainda onde não tinha Modern.
Eu vou chamar ela essa tarefa de Work Tree.
Vou chamar ela a Gee.
De Psique.
Eu vou abrir. Woman Pie.
Vou selecionar.
O Pro. Na verdade, eu vou fazer melhor. Tá.
Eu vou abrir o Flash.
Extra raiva da iolo. E vou pedir para ele fazer o cranking dessa atividade para mim.
Tá? Agora eu vou chamar uma outra.
Work Tree.
Vou chamar de W R.
Wrtr.
Opa.
Waitr.
Qual modelo vocês querem?
Chemi.
Vou vir aqui.
Vou virem Chemical Code.
Eu vou pedir para ele executar.
Vou criar uma outra Work Tree.
Vou chamar de.
W Rtr.
Vou chamar de Queen.
Vou vir aqui.
Dentro do homem. Pai.
Yolu Modi.
E vou chamar o Ken.
Três, oito.
Pró. Eu inesqueci.
Três.
Oito.
Ah, qual que é, Max, né.
Botar aqui no extra. High Yolu.
Eu vou pedir para ele fazer o cranking. Vou chamar de.
Edge to Angie.
Vamos ver se eles.
Faz um cranking. Vamos ver se a gente teve a sorte de passar enquanto ele já não tinha assinalado a Tarefa Para Ninguém Deixa Eu Ver Inclusive Aqui.
Que se ele já tiver feito o Hat, eu não consigo executar. Vai mostrar exatamente a validação. Então, se eu Ver Aqui Em Docs Tasks.
Ready, tá? Não assinali pra ninguém aqui a gente tem.
Teoricamente para a gente conseguir fazer. Sem problema. Ela não foi assinada para ninguém.
Oops.
Ok, eu tô sem acesso.
Isso aqui. Algum lag.
Isso aqui é algum problema do próprio? Na verdade.
Superintending. Ele não está deixando escrever.
Vamos ver se o Queen faz está instalando. Está fazendo o Booting do sistema, instalando porque ele não tem no Queen Então Ele Está Instalando Vamos Ver O Seguinte.
Luan. Chegando nesse nível de atomicidade, testa e Val, etc. Modelo pequeno, como Cohen da vida, ou até sete Bi consegue executar bem.
Essa é um bom teste. Vamos.
Deixar aqui.
Will key three.
Queen.
Qual vamos pegar um menor. Vamos pegar o sete B.
Vê que se a gente consegue.
Fecha. Oh, my pie.
Queen.
Braço sete B.
Qual? Esse aqui.
Qual desses aqui? Queen dois, cinco, dois, cinco, três, cinco, três, seis, dois, sete, B, dois sete B dois sete B.
Dois cinco sete B doiscinco, sete B. Acho que é esse aqui, né?
Beleza. Deep Flash, né? O Flash tá lembrando aqui. Flash.
Ah, não consegue fazer pelo contexto, que é muito grande.
Contexto.
Então vamos aumentar aqui só para um Queen.
Way.
Vamos pegar. Obviamente que esse cara vai funcionar, né?
Mas vamos lá. Boa, deixa eu pegar esse aí.
Também não vou pegar esse aqui. ó Queen tres cinco B, nove, bi.
Hm. Quite.
Hmm, quaint.
Três, cinco.
Nove, P.
O que o André está contando.
Está fazendo aqui?
Ah, tá we'll send. A máquina.
Conseguiu fazer? Vamos ver.
True.
Está indo, né?
To are coming from them.
Top. Vamos deixar aqui, né? Nem foi.
De Psique.
Flash.
Ele criou um plano, menino. Olha que coisa bonita.
Busca. Nada.
Fez o sign off. Tá vendo? Aqui mudou sign off true.
Signing off by sign off et beleza. Parece que ele pegou a tarefa.
Eu nunca tinha testado com Flash velho. Vai ser legal ver isso.
O Queen também. Deixa eu ver se ele conseguiu.
O Queen. Ele também fez o sign off coisa linda, né? Todos se comportam do mesmo jeito. Você tá doido?
Desks. Beleza mudou o endereço. Tá indo.
Vamos ver o Queen. Vamos ver o Kimmy. Beleza.
Então eu criei o Task Spec justamente para isso. Então.
Deixa eu mostrar uma coisa aqui pra vocês.
O Scork que o Ll me deu.
What keeps from perfect ten to ten the remaining zero point three Deficits due to Strict formatting adherence in smaller models.
Tá vendo? Geralmente as aleremos. Classificam o Task Spec.
Have you seen? Olha só.
Heaven. Si.
Have you seen something advanced like this on your entire code base something like task spec.
Can you also give me a Brief Introduction About Tasks Mesh.
Ele não pega, que come.
Vamos ver o que que é. Vamos ver o que que o.
O nosso Googli vai falar.
Desk Specswise and Converge represent a Major Paradigm Shift in Autonomous ai models interactive software repositories.
Region separation of powers eliminating the subjective Dawn.
The consensus barrier.
Uh, by frame develop relations.
Sinergics, it's Coordinating.
Forever. Sophisticated Design.
Possibly generally nunca viu.
Algo nesse nível, tipo uma parada extremamente extraordinária.
Can you just give me. A brief information about test smash.
Mesh. Olha só. Que legal que vocês vão aprender amanhã. O que é o Taskmash?
Ah, boa, boa, Thiago. O que é o Taskmash que tá dentro do Task Spec?
Vocês terem uma ideia. Taskmash é um control planning.
Opcional que está dentro da versão Tres nove que eu chipei.
Que basicamente utiliza o quê, né?
Eh.
Uma torre em relação aos tipos de agentes. Então ele orquestras logísticas.
Para poder fazer isso. Entendeu?
Então, basicamente.
Can you show me in the mermaid graph.
How Does The Task Mesh behaves.
When a task spends across different llms models.
Basicamente. O que faz esse carinha aqui? é.
Ele é muito foda. Ele coordena.
Múltiplas execuções teriam loop dentro do looping, né? Olha que coisa louca.
Vamos ver se ele mostra aqui.
Ah, não me fala que você não consegue gerar.
Um Mermaid graph, não é, irmão?
Me decepcionei.
Can you jitter.
Gonna generate a image instead. I can see the mermaid graph.
I can't.
Queria mostrar para vocês. Então ele coordena todo esse processo. Tá.
Deixa eu chutar o texto que vai falar amanhã? Tô cara Task. Em três modelos e um juiz de escolta Melhor Feito Para Subir O Pé.
Quase isso. Na verdade, ele é um Engines que vai.
Coordenar todos os níveis de execução.
Vamos voltar aqui. Vamos ver. ó.
Olha o bicho querendo. Olha o Queen sete bi.
Meu Deus!
Ansiedade.
Aqui. Foi.
Loucura, né, velho.
All Deep Cycles.
O Jeep Cycles foi lá e ainda fez o teste.
Cadê o Kimi? Kimi? Kimi Kimi não deu, né? Então vamos lá. Ele tá com algum problema.
No Environment dele. Vamos esperar o Queen normal. Obviamente que ele vai fazer.
Mais sinistro, né? Você pode executar diferentes em Gynes. Esse cara.
Cadê imagem? Irmão? Pediu imagem para você, velho.
Ah, tá. Tá aqui. Obrigado.
Ah, ficou ótimo. Realmente maravilhoso.
Entende tudo.
Também. Eu mostro pra vocês, tá? Mas basicamente um indign que vai controlar todas essas execuções aí pra gente com Diferentes Engines Então A Gente Entendeu Cara Que A Ideia.
é você decompor uma coisa grande numa coisa pequena.
Tá, então, basicamente é isso.
E executar esses caras ao longo do tempo. Para a gente poder, de fato, construir.
Um pequeno nível de trabalho.
E aí? Obviamente que ao longo dessa semana, a gente está na terça feira. A gente tem quarta, quinta e Sexta A Gente Vai Navegar No Task Pouquinho Em Pouquinho Para Entender.
Algumas características internas dele. Não dá para ver tudo, obviamente, mas a gente vai ver as principais características dele.
Depois. André, você vai falando aí como que tá? Mas parece que o código está saindo, né?
Ele fez dentro de Tnp Test Overpunch. Tá o teste.
Não sei. Estava especificado. Vamos ver se o código foi no local correto. Depois você dá uma olhada, vê se Ele Ficou Lá Dentro De Modern.
Beleza. Então o recap. A gente ainda não traduziu todo o código. A gente só verificou que o Task Spec.
Ele funciona porque a tradução do código vai acontecer somente quando a fábrica for ligada.
Então a gente vai lá na quinta e sexta começar a ver toda essa tradução acontecendo aqui. Eu só mostrei a método.
O que ele criou. O primeiro cara, tá? A gente vai fazer várias validações. Vai ter o Golden Match. Vai Ter Muita Coisa Que Vai Acontecer.
Dessa semana. Então a gente fechou o valor.
A gente começou a criar a primeira cabeça. Do que é o Java to pai.
A gente entendeu quais são os contratos que têm que ser feitos.
A gente criou os Adrs. A gente criou o Task Spec.
A gente falou um pouquinho do mesh que a gente vai entrar um pouquinho em detalhes amanhã e na quinta, principalmente.
E aí queria deixar algumas questões para vocês rodarem lá no D doze, tá, então, no D doze. Aqui tem Algumas Perguntas De Research Para Vocês Fazerem.
Mas não somente isso. Façam perguntas em relação ao projeto. Entendam, dissequem ele.
Então, cara, presta atenção que independentemente da arquitetura que você está fazendo aqui, a gente está criando um processo mental De Como Trabalhar Com Ele Em.
De uma forma extremamente eficiente, que você possa utilizar qualquer modelo.
Porque o Harness é o Molt, não a Llm.
Beleza. E aí me digam: gostaram de hoje?
Curtiram me. Fala aí na mensagem.
Se divertiram, foda, né.
Vocês têm semanas aí de estudo.
Vai abrir o repositório. Vai navegar. Vai entender. Vai usar, trabalhar com ele, expandir o seu.
O seu arsenal.
Tá beleza.
E eu vou deixar tempos aqui para vocês navegar tudo que a galera tá brincando?
Vai devagarzinho, tá? Eu não construí isso em um dia.
Então você também não vai entender em um dia só. Então fica tranquilo.
Queria documentos, entende? Vai questionando, perguntando, vendo os passos.
Tá. é.
Pô legal que tá rodando local. Depois, amanhã vocês trazem, né? O que vocês conseguiram executar do Steel Thread.
Que essa thread.
Pode perguntar, meu verão.
Obrigado aí pela apresentação. Já. Primeiro.
Eu estou com a seguinte dúvida que por que a intenção geral do objetivo era gerar código.
No final, as tarefas encadearam em geração de código. Mas para.
Por exemplo, se eu fizesse, sei lá. A intenção geral é ser um Gator de Api que vai descobrindo Apis Em Tempo De Execução E As Tarefas Fossem Alguma Coisa.
Porque a Pi chamar a partir do contexto anterior, e como se fosse meio que um.
Flow pensar que a gente ia fazer algo comoware Flow Inteligente.
Essa estrutura também daria para fazer esse tipo de coisa.
Mesma coisa. Sim.
Porque o processo é um esqueleto.
Você chegou a ter alguma coisa que você fez nesse sentido?
Sim, eu escrevi, na verdade, vários. Eu escrevi projetos de engenharia de dados de ai engineering, de software engineering de Context Engineering De Tudo Basicamente.
Principalmente sistemas de orquestração.
O sistema orquestrar o outro, por exemplo.
Criar Degas, executar entre eles códigos de Databrics, códigos, deflow, sistemas para criar o código deflow.
Então, basicamente é uma fábrica que você coloca qualquer coisa que você quiser que rode num.
Num processo técnico de tecnologia, qualquer coisa.
Então eu quero criar um processo que vigie um outro processo. Eu quero criar um processo que transforma em outro processo.
Independentemente, né? Vai chegar um requisito. Vai ser transformado num requisito técnico. Vai ser quebrado em Edrs. Vai ser cortado.
O nível vai gerar uma tarefa pequena e vai ser executado. Então vai seguir esse fluxo.
E aí tem uma coisa legal que o converge. Vai ter lições. Ele vai aprendendo.
Então, quanto mais ele aprende, mais ele entende o seu contexto como um todo. Então ele vai ter essa facilidade De Entender Exatamente O Que Acontece Dentro Do Sistema.
Máscara. Obrigado.
Testem e me avisem, tá?
Mas, cara, isso aí, são.
Fund. é um projeto que eu tenho trabalhado nos últimos, sei lá, oito meses. Sete meses? Não tem muita coisa aí dentro.
Então vocês vão descobrir muita coisa aí dentro. Legal que dá para você reusar, que dá pra melhorar, que dá Para Expandir O Que Você Já Tem De Você Usar No Dia A Dia.
Então vocês vão curtir.
Está usando o que aqui Queen.
Tres seis, trinta e cinco, Bi. Legal.
Olha o código. Olha o código!
Legal.
Bonit. Costa.
Foda.
Quem diria, hein? Eu podia usar um Llm local, hein, André? Para escrever o mesmo código de um Llm Frontier num processo.
Poda, né? Não conseguiria fazer isso se não fosse por processo. Framework não dá.
Simplesmente tá.
Então é isso, gente foda. Amanhã a gente vai continuar. Esse rolê.
Eh? E a gente vai escrever essa fábrica inteira desse processo. Tá.
Tamo junto. A gente se vê amanhã. Tá? Até mais.